Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Hast du noch.
Ich glaube, ich habe Sirup Covid, aber ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass das äh um mich herum noch viel Sirup geholt gibt.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertvierundsiebzig vom zweiundzwanzigsten zwölften zwanzig zwanzig. Das Weihnachtsfest rauscht heran. Und äh hast du schon alle Geschenke äh eingepackt für dich?
Selber da der Isolation Ninus.
Ich habe mir ich habe einige noch nicht ausgepackt, aber dafür verpacken wir ihr jetzt ein schönes Geschenk für unsere Hörerinnen, nämlich ein ein Weihnachtsmärchen vom.
Genau, es war einmal vor langer, langer Zeit, als ein Virus ausging. Die Menschheit zu erobern, aber äh ein gallisches Dorf auf diesem Planeten
wollte es nicht haben das Geschenk. Ja, wir haben äh eine Gestern nämlich äh Katharinen Katharintha, hallo.
Und ja äh wir wollen ein wenig ähm erzählen aus fernen Landen äh denn da bist du nämlich gerade, du bist vor drei Wochen in,
Taiwan aufgeschlagen.
Fast vier Wochen mittlerweile. Ähm ich habe das sehr genau im Auge, weil ich sehr genau weiß, man man zählt so ein bisschen die Tage, aber da kommen sicher auch noch drauf.
Ja, genau.
Denn äh das ist so ein bisschen unser Fokus heute in dieser Sendung. Wir wollen uns mal äh äh ja darüber unterhalten, weil in Deutschland die Diskussion ja wie wir alle wissen, äh links, nach Kreuz, nach quer geht.
Und ähm ja, das ist natürlich in Taiwan eine ganz andere Geschichte. Hm, vielleicht steigen wir doch damit äh,
mal ein, dass du mal kurz äh dann deine Situation mal vor Ort hast, dass wir das mal alles äh verstehen können.
Genau, also ich bin jetzt in einfach so ganz normal
bis vor elf Tagen war ich allerdings in Quarantäne also ich bin Ende November gelandet und musste dann quasi zwei Wochen,
War's dann in einem Hotelzimmer und durfte auch nicht raus. Ähm sicherzugehen, dass ich quasi nicht ähm.
Äh Covid fahren lassen so. Und jetzt ähm bin ich aber raus ähm und äh habe im Wesentlichen so ein ganz normales Leben,
So, also ich äh war am Wochenende feiern äh in dem Technoclub tatsächlich.
Na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na. Ja.
Ähm.
Für heute, ähm ich war, ich bin Fahrrad gefahren, war bei einem Buchladen ähm und dann habe ich danach äh in einem Cafe so ein bisschen gearbeitet, äh weil ich arbeite ja als Journalistin
und hab dann an MTEX gearbeitet und dann bin ich war ich in 'nem Restaurant essen und jetzt bin ich wieder zu Hause, also.
Während unserer Hörerinnen noch äh die Träne aus dem Knopfloch heraus schälen.
Hörerin, die haben wir doch jetzt längst verloren.
So
Sind alle ausgeschaltet.
Da ist will ich nicht hören. Ähm äh erzähl doch mal, wie das so genau lief. Wie fing denn das an? Also äh du musstest dich vermutlich,
erstmal irgendwie auch melden oder überhaupt erstmal eine Einreisegenehmigung haben oder sowas, oder?
Genau, also man kommt mit normalen ähm.
Man muss ein bestimmtes Visum haben, also das Visum, das ich jetzt gerade habe für Taiwan, da steht extra drin, dass ich ein ähm während der Covid-Neunzehn-Pandemie habe.
Da meinte schon ein Freund von mir, dass ich da so ein bisschen so ein Vibe hat von so resident evil äh oder so. Ähm das heißt, man braucht, man muss ein Visum beantragen, ähm die kriegt man durchaus auch noch.
Und dann, wenn man das Visum hat, ähm muss man allerdings äh
Diverse Sachen machen. Man muss ähm zum einen, man muss nicht nur einen Flug buchen, sondern muss auch einen Covid-PCR-Test äh Termin buchen. Und zwar ein PCR-Test, der nicht mehr als zweiundsiebzig Stunden vorm Abflug
genommen werden darf und man muss dann zum Abflug ein negatives Ergebnis haben. Das heißt, grade in Deutschland ist das dann auch so eine gewisse logistische Herausforderung, wenn man dann einen Test finden muss, wenn man weiß, dass man das Ergebnis ähm schnell kriegt.
Und nicht irgendwie eine Woche auf das Testergebnis wartet.
Von wo aus bist du geflogen? Und konntest du dann in Berlin gibt's ja so ein Testzentrum. Hast du das dann genommen?
Ich war ähm in Mitte bei so einer Praxis, die das anbietet. Ähm und genau, also das war ich war auch sehr überrascht, dass das Ergebnis dann irgendwie innerhalb von zwölf Stunden kam oder so oder vierzehn, das ging wirklich sehr schnell.
Ähm und.
Genau und das muss man machen und dann muss man außerdem noch ähm sich überlegen, wo man seine Quarantäne macht, weil man muss halt nach Einreise, zwei Wochen Quarantäne machen. Leute, die ähm so permanent Residency hier haben.
Oder ähm einen tavenesischen Pass, können das zu Hause machen, ähm als Person auf so einem Besucher in, wieso muss ich das in einem Hotel machen? Und das heißt, man muss außerdem noch ein Hotel buchen,
Das heißt, man muss also auch so ein logistisches Tetris so ein bisschen, wenn man diesen Test, einen Flug, der wahrscheinlich nicht gecancelt wird, ähm und dieses Hotel irgendwie koordinieren muss und diese Hotels, das kann auch nicht jedes Hotel machen, da gibt's bestimmte Hotels, die dafür
ähm designiert sind. Das heißt, da muss auch einen freien Platz in einem Hotel finden, das man sich leisten kann. Ähm und also zumindest, als ich,
So das letzte Mal geguckt habe, ähm so Hotels, die so mittlere bis obere Preisklasse sind, die sind auch schon zwei bis drei Wochen im voraus ausgebucht. Ähm und gerade so billigere Sachen, was so unter hundert Euro pro Nacht ist, das ist echt ähm da muss man,
das ist eigentlich soweit ausgebucht, wie weit man da die Buchungen nachschauen kann.
Das heißt, du musst allein schon mal zweitausend Euro nur auf Quarantäne äh verwenden.
Na, kommt drauf an. Also, es geht also es geht auch schon ähm wie gesagt, man man kriegt auch für irgendwie fünfzig bis siebzig Euro was. Man kriegt auch theoretisch für zwanzig Euro was, aber ich weiß nicht, ob man das will für zwei Wochen
und es geht alles hoch bis zweihundert Euro pro Nacht, aber das kann sich halt auch also
Das ist dann da, das ist dann auch so eine so da so gibt's dann so natürliche Grenzen.
Ja, aber das sollte die Freiheit einem doch wert sein.
Ja gut, dann ist halt auch wieder eine Frage, was man sich leisten kann.
Ja klar, Freiheit muss man sich natürlich leisten können. So so einfach ist es nicht. So und dann bist du am Flughafen angekommen und was ist dann passiert?
Das irgendwie mit Taten, die ähm Angestellten der Airline etwas leid, weil sie für alle fliegende mussten sie quasi sicher gehen, dass die Leute, die Einreisebestimmungen für das jeweilige Land,
erfüllen. Das heißt, vor mir ähm ist jemand nach Hongkong geflogen und die mussten mit denen abkaspern, ob sie das äh für Hongkong erfüllen. Und hinter mir ist jemand irgendwie nach Russland geflogen oder so und musste beweisen, dass das irgendwie für Russland erfüllt und bei mir mussten sie sicher gehen, dass ich die Sachen für Tayone erfülle. Also ist wirklich.
Ziemlich chaotisch gerade.
Also es war kein Direktflug, wenn ich das mal so richtig interpretiere.
Ah nee genau, ich bin erst nach Amsterdam geflogen und dann von Amsterdam ähm nach äh nach Taipé.
Okay.
Genau und
ich musste also den PCR-Test schon vorzeigen. Ich musste vorzeigen, dass ich eine Buchung habe fürs Quarantänehotel. Ähm und ich musste zeigen, dass ich mich in so ein ähm das gibt's jetzt in Deutschland, glaube ich, auch, aber anders
Aber so und es gibt jetzt so ein Einreiseportal, wo man sich quasi einträgt und anmeldet. Ähm das muss man, ich glaube, man darf das maximal ein oder zwei Tage vor Abreise ausfüllen.
Und da trägt man dann quasi ein ich komme genau dann und dann an, mit dem und dem Flug und da mache ich meine Quarantäne und das ist mein Pass. Das ist vom ähm Gesundheitsministerium, die quasi so tracken,
Wer Quarantäne macht und das wird halt auch echt überprüft. Also das wurde sowohl bei dem Check-In und dann auch nochmal beim Boarding für den direkten Flug. Ähm wurde sicher gegangen, dass ich die Dokumente wirklich alle habe und dass ich das alles gemacht habe.
Mhm. Okay und dann während des Flugs natürlich alle mit Masken auf und so weiter.
Genau, aber also auch wenn man in so einem ähm also der Flug nach Amsterdam war echt ziemlich voll. Da wäre ich auch etwas überrascht.
Aber danach Taipe waren wir irgendwie, also es ist halt so ein riesiges Flugzeug, das halt integriert, da waren halt irgendwie dreißig oder vierzig Leute drin.
Das heißt, ähm man hat so viel Platz wie im Leben noch nicht gehabt auf irgendeinem, auf irgendeinem Flug. Ähm und genau, wenn man dann in Teppich ankommt, jetzt eigentlich erst richtig interessant.
Weil da das Flugzeug wird halt behandelt wie so eine Kontaminierung, so wie so eine kontaminierte Zone, ne. Das ist halt so ein Fremdkörper, der dann nach TPP kommt. Und.
Alle Leute werden als potenziell infiziert behandelt im Wesentlichen. Also da steigen dann die ganzen Reisenden aus. Ähm und die müssen dann alle nochmal, man muss dann nochmal nachweisen, dass man sich in dieses System eingetragen hat.
Da ist dann auch so, und da gibt's quasi so, das ist ein bisschen man hatte so Stationen
Bei der einen Station stehen ganz viele Flughafenangestellte, die einem quasi helfen, das Ding auszufüllen nochmal und bei der anderen Station kann man sich eine tabinesische SIM-Karte kaufen, weil man für die Quarantäne eine tabinesische Nummer braucht. Das heißt, ich musste mein System, musste das dann nochmal ausfüllen,
quasi ähm um oder um quasi die tavenesische Nummer noch mit einzutragen, die ich mir dann am Flughafen direkt geholt hatte.
Und da haben halt auch irgendwie alle Schutzmasken auf und alles. Ähm und genauso viele viele bis die meisten, die da waren.
Hatten ähm nicht nur Maske, sondern hatten auch Maske, so eine Schutzbrille und Handschuhe und ein paar Leute laufen aber auch so in komplett ähm.
Schutzmontur rum. Also das variiert so ein bisschen. Und aber auch diese Eintragung des Einreisesystem wird dann irgendwie, ich glaube, die wurde dreimal überprüft oder so, bevor ich überhaupt meinen Pass vorzeigen musste irgendwo.
Und äh dann bei bei der Passkontrolle wird dann nochmal geguckt, okay, haben sie wirklich negativen Kurvestest? Okay, ja, hm, ähm wo, wo sie Quarantäne Hotel, ja, hier, also wirklich alles, alles doppelt und dreifach und vierfach.
Und äh dann durfte ich ähm endlich raus und durfte aber auch nicht in den Nahverkehr, weil es wird halt davon ausgegangen, jede Person, die aus dem Ausland kommt, hat potenziell.
Kann man sich den Tabak nicht leisten. Ähm und deswegen ähm fährt man, es gibt so Taxis, die nur Leute in die Quarantäne fahren im Wesentlichen
Das wird auch alles registriert, wenn mit welchem Taxi fährt. Und da bin ich dann quasi ähm einfach mit einem Taxi äh direkt in die Stadt gefahren und das hat mich dann direkt per Hotel abgesetzt.
Und das Taxi war wahrscheinlich der Fahrer und der Transport, der Gasbereich getrennt und so, oder?
Ähm ich war gar nicht getrennt, glaube ich sogar, aber genau hatte halt, er hat halt auch äh Maske und Handschuhe an. Und,
Dann aber, als ich beim Hotel angekommen bin, ähm hat's so ein Hotelangestellter, der hätte wirklich volle Manturen, auch so ein so ein so ein Medizinkittel so ähm und und Maske und Handschuhe und alles. Und der hat dann erstmal,
das ganze Taxi desinfiziert. Also erstmal mein mein Gepäck desinfiziert,
Gepäck rausgenommen, dann den ganzen Kofferraum und dann hat er die Taxifahrer gefragt, okay, wo hat sie gesessen? Also zeigt, okay, nochmal großzügig den den Sitz hinten eingesprüht. Ähm bevor ich dann überhaupt in das Hotel einchecken durfte.
Und auch der Check-in-Prozess war halt so, ähm ich musste mich dann erstmal in so ein kleines Quadrat stellen ähm und dann halt erst mal, wenn eine Temperatur gemessen, weil wenn ich Fieber gehabt hätte, das wäre gar also hätten sie mich wahrscheinlich direkt irgendwo ins Krankenhaus geschickt und dann hätte ich erst reingelassen.
Und dann haben sie meine meine Schuhe desinfiziert und meine Hände und dann habe ich so, so, so, so Schuhcovers gekriegt oder so, die man so über die Schuhe zieht,
Ähm und dann haben sie mich wirklich erst eingecheckt. Ähm.
Und das auch nicht in den am normalen und nicht an einem normalen Scheck in Prozess, sondern einfach so äh unten quasi im Flur, wo man normalerweise eigentlich nur die ähm,
den Aufzug nimmt. Und dann haben sie mich, als ich da eingecheckt war, haben sie gesagt, okay, so und so, kriegst aber einen Tag kriegst Essen. Dann habe ich gesagt, okay, jetzt nimmst du den Aufzug und fährst in äh ich glaube im neunten Stock oder so und ähm viel Spaß.
Oder warst du in deinem Zimmer oder bist du in zwei Wochen nicht rausgekommen?
Genau,
Das muss man vielleicht auch, also das haben wir jetzt noch gar nicht so gesagt, aber ähm die Leute sind so vorsichtig, weil Taiwan ähm bis heute. Ähm zweihundertdreiundfünfzig Tage lang kein
lokal übertragen, einen Gefall von Covid neunzehn hatte. Ähm und das ist halt alles ein das ganze System ist halt da, um das zu erhalten so ein bisschen. Also das müssen wir uns als kurze Erklärung für, warum die alle so vorsichtig sind.
Ja, das ist ein richtiger Hinweis, also Zero-Covid äh äh ist in Taiwan eine Realität, wie er auch in Neuseeland und sonst, glaube ich, nur in sehr wenigen anderen Ländern, wisst ihr jetzt gerade gar nicht, wen ich mit Sicherheit nennen könnte.
Vietnam ist, glaube ich, auch noch ganz gut dabei. Ähm die Mongolei ist auch sehr gut dabei. Ähm Australien hat jetzt wieder gerade ein paar Fälle gehabt. Ähm aber versuchen das auch mit. Ähm es gibt schon so ein paar.
China auch selber.
Ähm ja gibt halt immer wieder Fälle, ne? Also ich finde das ein großes Land.
Japan hat's bis Juni ganz gut im Griff gehabt. Also nicht auf zero, aber.
Ich glaube, was in diesen Ländern wirklich interessant ist, ist, dass sie wirklich alles auf Zero machen. Ähm und das ist halt in China auch, glaube ich, die,
So das Ziel, aber einfach dadurch, dass Kino so groß ist, hat man halt immer wieder Ausbrüche, deswegen hat man ich finde das so problematisch, dass wir davon Streaks reden, weil ich bei Streets immer an Dulingo denke. Und wenn so Sachen, aber äh Tai-One hatte halt den längsten Streak von,
einem Land ohne Covid-Infektionen.
Also den längsten Lauf oder was wäre die korrekte Überraschsetzung dafür, ja.
Ja, genau. Und Vietnam hatte, glaube ich, drei Monate, bevor es jetzt kürzlich einen Ausbruch gab, ähm und so solange es in China fast einfach sehr schwierig, weil das Land einfach sehr groß ist ähm und auch immer noch viel.
Austausch mit dem Rest der Welt tatsächlich stattfindet, ähm der es dann doch etwas erschwert.
Aber es zeigt vor allem na ja, ne, wenn man sich schon diese ganze Mühe macht, wenn man's einmal auf null hat, heißt das nicht, dass die Anstrengungen aufhören, sondern dass sie beibehalten werden, ne, dass man zwar einerseits sagt, okay.
Wir können jetzt irgendwie die Leute in Clubs und in Cafes gehen lassen, aber wir müssen natürlich trotzdem also wir können die Anstrengungen nicht fallen lassen und das scheint ja so ein bisschen die beiden Feder äh gewesen zu sein, die.
Viele andere Staaten, sagen wir mal, im in der Phase von April bis Juni gemacht haben, dass sie die Zahl nahe null, aber nicht auf null.
Gelassen bekommen haben und dann irgendwie gesagt haben, ach cool, jetzt können wir lockern. Und das beißt jetzt irgendwie.
Spätestens seit ähm ich habe den Eindruck, Oktober weltweit eigentlich fast alle Staaten ähm in in die.
Instinks.
Ich würde sagen, ähm eher so so Europa und Nordamerika kann man so grundsätzlich sagen, das ist ein Problem.
Ähm außerhalb davon variiert es sehr, also viele afrikanische Länder stehen, so werde ich das auf dem Schirm aber auch sehr gut da Asien hat relativ viel Varianz. Ähm,
grade so, also aber ähm zum Beispiel es gibt auch Winterwellen hier, also Hongkong und Südkorea kämpfen da gerade sehr mit. Ähm und Japan auch,
Aber die haben halt auch trotzdem vorher schon auf einem ganz anderen Niveau operiert als ähm als Europa. Da gibt's halt jetzt eine Windelwelle, aber die findet halt auf einem viel niedrigeren Niveau statt.
Also ich glaube, so weltweit gesehen muss man wirklich sagen, dass es ein europäisches und nordamerikanisches Problem ist.
Also ich meinte damit, wenn ich wenn ich hier bei bei Google kriege ich ja, wenn man irgendwie einen Ort eingibt und dahinter Corona, dann kriegt man direkt so eine schöne Kurve gemalt.
Aber die hat natürlich eine immer eine angepasste Y-Achse.
Und man sieht, die hat eigentlich immer die gleiche Kurvenform, aber wenn man dann mal an den Peak geht, dann sieht man eben ja sechsundzwanzig und nicht äh so und so viel tausend, ja.
Und das macht natürlich den Unterschied aus zwischen das ist jetzt ein Problem oder das ist eine eine Herausforderung, ja. Das ist klar, klarer Unterschied.
Genau und ich glaube, wie du eben sagtest, auch dieses reaktive versus und rausschauendes Handeln, das ist echt eine riesige Unterschied. Weil ähm in Taiwan ähm.
Haben zum Beispiel Leute auch trotzdem, obwohl ähm obwohl es seit April eigentlich keinen Fall gab, äh haben viele unter die Maske getragen. Die Maskenregeln wurden dann auch nochmal verschärft Anfang Dezember und dann haben noch mehr Leute Maske getragen.
In der U-Bahn wird zum Beispiel Temperatur gemessen bevor man reingeht, also die haben so ein Temperaturmessding wo man so vorbeiläuft wenn man über achtunddreißig Grad hat darf man nicht mitfahren.
Ähm so solche Sachen.
Was ist, wenn man, wenn man achtunddreißig Grad Attest hat zum Beispiel?
Also hä? Attest.
Kommst du damit durch?
Ja nun ähm ich meine ja, die Coronazahlen sprechen für sich, ne. Ähm ich glaube, dass das, das krasse ist halt so ein bisschen, ich habe in Deutschland immer das Gefühl gehabt, ich glaube,
Sachen, die in Deutschland gemacht wurden, ähm als die also in Deutschland sind so solche Maßnahmen wie Masken so was macht man, wenn's richtig schlimm ist. In Taiwan macht man das, damit es nicht schlimm wird. Und das ist der große Unterschied.
Dass hier viel früher und das ist auch so ein Muster, das sich durch viele andere
ostasiatische Länder auch, zieht das oft Maßnahmen viel früher und bei viel niedrigeren Zahlen schon eingeführt werden. Ähm und zum Beispiel in Taiwan wurden im ähm
Taiwan hat ja viel Flugverkehr mit China und hatte am Anfang auch sehr schnell äh Corona-Fälle im im Januar, am achtundzwanzigsten ersten gab's, glaube ich, den ersten bestätigten Fall. Und die haben dann, so als sie bei so zweistelligen, ich glaube, irgendwie so sagt man so.
Fünfzehn, zwanzig, Covid-Fälle pro Tag. Ähm aber die haben halt gesehen, was in Ohan abgegangen ist und die haben gesagt, das können wir uns nicht leisten. Das darf nicht hier, das darf hier einfach nicht passieren.
Und dann haben die halt im Februar die Schulen zugemacht zum Beispiel. Als sie bei fünfzehn Coronafällen pro Tag waren. Ähm und haben halt wirklich.
Dass dieses Virus in Grund und Boden Kontakt verfolgt ähm und haben dann eben diese Ausbrüche äh es gab mehrere so kleine Ausbrüche im Inland, haben die einfach einen nach dem anderen ähm unterdrückt,
Und ähm immer also bei jeder Infektion Kontakte finden, Kontakte in Quarantäne. Ähm wenn da jemand positiv ist, auch sofort Kontakte finden, Kontakte in Quarantäne, bis das Virus einfach ähm,
sich ausgebrannt hat.
Das ist ja wirklich das Faszinierende. Also solche, ne, die die frühen Maßnahmen, die es wirklich die geeignet sind, ist im Keim zu ersticken. Hm.
Die werden in Deutschland auch heute noch belächelt, ne? Also wenn du jemandem sagst, guck mal hier, wie das.
In Taiwan geregelt wurde oder wie lange Japan, Japan hat jetzt glaube ich so Inzidenzenne, wobei,
zwei dreitausend, das ist jetzt auch nicht mehr irgendwie äh Taiwan, aber die haben's auch sehr lange, sehr gut unter Kontrolle gehalten und in Japan gibt es Metropolen von Größen,
die sich in in Europa, die man vorstellen kann, ne? Aber wenn man sagt, guck mal hier diese Maßnahmen, dann wird auch immer abgewunken und gesagt
ach ja, völlig übertrieben, das sind ja alles Paranoe, obwohl alle Daten und aller Erfolg diesen Maßnahmen recht gibt. Und ich erinnere mich da an ähm.
Ein Aspekt, den den Tim in der letzten Folge UKW auch so genannt hat, ne? Wenn du die Maßnahmen nicht von vornherein mit aller erbarmungslosen,
Härte durchziehst und mit einem konkreten Ziel und die Maßnahmen dann erst lockerst, wenn du das Ziel auch erreicht hast, dann erreichst du, wenn du das nicht tust, dann erreichst du eben leider auch das Ziel nicht.
Und dieses Ziel scheint es ja dann doch irgendwie wert zu sein, weil,
irgendwie, wenn du das jetzt so schilderst, er belasse ich vor Neid, weil die Einschränkungen ja relativ gering sind. Gibt es denn in Taiwan auch irgendwie Bevölkerungsströmungen.
Die jetzt beispielsweise sich durch ihre schweren Einschränkungen durch das Wehren der durch das Tragen von Masken im öffentlichen Raum wehren.
Ähm ich habe davor noch nichts mitgekriegt, ehrlich gesagt. Und ich wäre ziemlich überrascht. Also ein paar komische Leute gibt es sicher. Es gab auch vor ein paar Tagen so eine Trump-Rallye irgendwie hier und da waren dann Leute ohne Maske, aber,
Ganz ehrlich, also ich war Deutschland schon lange nicht mehr im Nahverkehr, auch schon bevor ich geflogen bin. Ich bin einfach über mit Fahrrad angefahren,
Aber ähm in in der U-Bahnen Taipe tragen mehr Leute Maske als in der ähm zum Berliner Nahverkehr, als ich das letzte Mal im Berliner Nahverkehr war. Also irgendwie, keine Ahnung, September oder so.
Aber das heißt, es gibt Leute ohne.
Vielleicht so ganz verschwindend gering, aber es ist halt kein großer Teil des Diskurses irgendwie, weil es auch schon viel, also es gibt, es sind spielen ganz viele Faktoren da mit rein, aber es ist halt viel normalisierter, eine Maske zu tragen, also auch zum Beispiel, wenn ich in wenn ich in ähm,
in Ostasien bin und auch als ich in in Taiwan gelebt habe, wenn ich krank war, habe ich mir halt eine Maske aufgesetzt. Ähm weil.
Einfach grundsätzliche Höflichkeit. Ich versuche halt, ähm andere Leute nicht anzustecken. Ähm das heißt, Leute tragen Maske, um sich äh um andere Leute nicht krank zu machen. Im Intervant fahren superviele Leute Scooter. Ganz viele Leute tragen auf dem Scooter
wenn wenn sie hier so durch die Stadt fahren Maske, um sich vor der Luftverschmutzung zu schützen, weil sie hätten an der Straße sind. Manche Leute tragen halt einfach Maske, wenn sie verkatert sind und kein Bock hatten, sich irgendwie Schminke,
draufzusetzen oder so. Also ganz viele verschiedene Gründe. Das heißt, es ist etwas, was viel normalisierter ist
und auch wenn man hier irgendwie Fernsehen guckt oder so bei den ganzen Pressekonferenzen, ähm tragen Leute alle Maske. Das ist halt einfach viel.
Ähm ich verstehe tatsächlich auch, vielleicht bin ich da eher asiatisch irgendwie sozialisiert, aber ich verstehe tatsächlich auch diese diese Proteste in Deutschland irgendwie nicht, weil das halt so ein das ist halt, ich,
so ein bisschen, das ist halt ein dünnes Stück.
Zum medizinischen Schutzstoff, den setzt man sich auf und das merkt man kaum und wenn man dadurch irgendwie andere Leute oder sich schützen kann, dann macht man das halt. Das ist so ein bisschen.
Es ist halt, glaube ich, auch in Asien. Ich tue mich ein bisschen schwer, das zu generalisieren, weil ich eigentlich äh Asien relativ wenig äh kenne, aber auch so ich war mal in Japan und es äh da,
da ist einfach dieser Individualismus nicht so dominant. Ja, wie das bei uns ist, ne.
Das halte ich das finde ich schwierig. Also würde ich so nicht unterschreiben. Also es gibt auch hier super viele Leute, die egoistisch sind und keinen Bock haben, sich in die Regeln zu halten so. Es gibt immer wieder auch Fälle von Leuten, die halt ähm.
Die halt zum Beispiel Quarantäne brechen, weil sie unbedingt irgendwie eine Party feiern mussten oder unbedingt irgendwie zum Covian Store gehen wollten.
Ich habe auch nicht gesagt,
nicht. Ich habe nur gesagt, es ist nicht so dominant. Ja, also ich würde schon sagen, dass das sozusagen in Deutschland ist das auch schon so so fast so ein Mantra, ne. So und Amerika ist es halt noch schlimmer, ne. Also wenn die Leute dann schon irgendwie so demonstrieren gegen diese Maßnahmen mit, dann weißt du irgendwie schon, wo's äh herkommt, während
man also dieses äh Masketragen ja auch immer schon so einen Ausdruck von ähm ich will jetzt hier gar nicht den anderen zur Last fallen äh
wahr meiner Wahrnehmung.
Sorry, ich kann das nicht nur als äh als eine Phase eine Form von Individualismus sehen. Ich meine klar, Individualismus,
treibt Leute in relativ dumme Dinge, die sie tun, ja, nur um sich irgendwie besonders zu fühlen, aber das ist nicht der, die ausreichende ähm.
Erklärung dafür, dass es hier Bewegungen gibt, die meinen, dass der der wichtige Kampf,
der aktuellen Zeit sei, sich dagegen zu wehren, sich ein blödes Stück äh Stoff vor die Maske zu äh äh vors Gesicht zu hängen. Da brauchst du noch ein bisschen mehr für als nur, irgendwie mehr oder weniger Individualismus. Da brauchst du irgendwie auch eine.
Eine massive Bratpfanne an den Kopf.
Ja und ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich auch eine Sozialisierung so ein bisschen, weil's einfach viel normalisierter ist. Also ich glaube, man darf echt nicht unterschätzen, was das auch mit einem macht. Also Kinder wachsen halt hier auf und die sehen halt, dass manchmal Menschen eben Maske tragen,
oder auch also diese ganze Diskussion ob Kinder Maske tragen können oder nicht, das ist aus asiatischer Perspektive total bizarr, weil ich sehe hier Mütter
eine Freundin von mir hat mir neulich erzählt, sie war in der U-Bahn und dann war da halt eine Mutter mit Kind im Kinderwagen und dann hat die Mutter gesagt, ah okay, wir gehen jetzt in die Metro rein, Moment, ich setze jetzt eben deine Maske auf, weil wenn wir in die Metro gehen, setzen wir Maske auf. Ähm das machen wir so,
Ähm und also das und deswegen habe ich auch das mit dem Fernsehen und so gesagt und das ist halt auch so viel normalisiert, dass es hat mit Kollektivismus gar nicht unbedingt was, also wenn ich irgendwie
Finde, dass dass mein Gesicht grade scheiße aussieht, weil ich verkatert bin. Ich nicht möchte, dass mein Boss das sieht, ähm dann hat das ja nichts mit Kollektivismus zu tun, ne. Also es ist halt einfach, es gibt verschiedene Gründe, warum man das macht, aber es ist einfach generell als etwas, was man halt tut, ähm phänomalisierter und man wird nicht komisch angeguckt.
Hier zu der normalisierten oder zu der normalen Bedeutung einer Maske, was ich in Japan äh zu Beginn dieser Zeit äh beobachtet habe, waren viele Schilder, die zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, im Hotel an der Rezeption, in Restaurants oder so waren
sinngemäß unsere Angestellten tragen Masken aus reiner Vorsichtsmaßnahme nicht, weil sie krank sind,
offenbar da von vielen Leuten interpretiert wird als OK Person hat 'ne Maske,
aus dem Weg gehen, weil die wird ja ein Grund haben, dass sie diese Maske trägt und jetzt habe ich ein ungutes Gefühl damit, dass sie mir Nahrung zum Beispiel serviert oder zubereitet, ne? Da gab's also relativ häufig diese Schilder, die darauf hingewiesen haben, wo die jetzt.
Ne, wenn Masken diese Bedeutung nicht für dich haben in Deutschland, also für mich war das nicht unbedingt mit.
So stark mit Fremdschutz assoziiert zu Beginn dieser ganzen Zeit, sondern eben mit Selbstschutz,
sodass sich äh geschmunzelt habe darüber, dass es diese Schilder gab. Also das ist wahrscheinlich das, was du auch ein bisschen meinst mit was ist.
Wie normal ist eine Maske und was assoziiere ich damit, dass jemand eine trägt?
Ja, genau, total. Und Japan ist auch so ein Land, wo man das auch macht, wenn man halt selber krank ist. Ähm dass man so oder mit man eben nicht die ganzen Leute an die seinen,
irgendwie überverteilt. Deswegen finde ich auch eigentlich, es ist eine gute Gewohnheit und ich würde mich freuen, wenn das eine Gewohnheit ist, die wir irgendwie mitnehmen können äh in die Zeit nach der Pandemie. Das die irgendwann kommt,
weil das natürlich auch generell helfen kann so Erkältungen und solche Sachen,
Das weniger verbreitet, aber ich habe eher das Gefühl, so die Attitüde, also es ist so eine so schon so eine Einstellungssache, dass in Deutschland ist eher so ein bisschen die Attitüde, sobald man einen Grund hat, die Maske nicht zu tragen, legt man sie halt ab.
Und ähm hier ist jetzt grad eher so ein bisschen so, okay, ja die blöde Maske so. Max, merk's ja nicht.
So, jetzt hast du vorhin ja erwähnt, dass äh Taiwan das Ziel Zero Covid hatte und das bis heute auch geschafft hat, aber wenn ich's richtig sehe, äh ist es seit heute auch kaputt gegangen. Was ist denn da passiert?
Ah ja ähm also ein alter, weiser Mann ist passiert.
Zumindest äh zieht das Internet tadanesische Internet gerade über alte weiße Männer her, weil ein,
Also ein ein Pilot aus Neuseeland, der für eine ähm für eine tavenesische Airline arbeitet, hat wohl sich irgendwo Covid geholt.
Und hat das ging schon mal sehr gut damit los, als äh seinen Fall gestern veröffentlicht wurde. Ähm er hatte sich nämlich geweigert, im Flugzeug eine Maske zu tragen, hat er dann prompt zwei von seinen Kolleginnen angesteckt.
Er war auch der Meinung, dass er keine Symptome hätte ähm und dann haben ihn aber wohl
irgendjemand hat ihn bei den Behörden verpfifft und hat gesagt, der war definitiv am Husten, während wir im Flugzeug waren. Und daraufhin wurde er überhaupt erst gefunden. Also der hätte sich auch nicht von alleine gemeldet.
Und dann ähm also eigentlich muss man halt vierzehn Tage Quarantäne machen, wenn man ins Land kommt. Das ist auch ziemlich ähm gnadenlos und es gibt wirklich, es ist wirklich sehr schwierig, eine Ausnahme zu kriegen. Ähm aber ähm es gibt Ausnahmen für Airline Crews,
und äh das ist äh das ist dann halt bei ihm da äh viele da drunter.
Ich wusste, dass es so eine Ausnahme gibt, wo äh wo die Crews äh nur zehn Tage machen müssen. Aber er musste wohl nur drei Tage Quarantäne machen. Und das heißt, nicht nur hat er seine seine ganzen Symptome verschwiegen und so und sich lange ähm lange quasi so getan, als sei er in Ordnung, sondern,
kann zwar nur drei Tage Quarantäne machen, muss danach aber eigentlich noch so ein paar grundsätzliche Regeln befolgen, die auch ich in der Woche nach meiner Quarantäne noch bevor musste. Also das ist zum Beispiel sich von Menschenmengen fernhalten, Maske tragen, weil man mit anderen Menschen irgendwie Umgang hat ähm und
äh generell so ein bisschen vorsichtig sein und auch so ein bisschen Symptome beobachten, zweimal am Tag Fieber messen solche Sachen. Und ähm stattdessen.
Hat er sich halt irgendwie mit irgendwelchen Leuten getroffen, ähm hat war wohl irgendwie bei mehreren social guater ranks. Es gibt jetzt irgendwie gerüstet, dass er vielleicht eine Affäre mit jemandem hatte und ähm als dann feststand, dass er covid hatte, hat er auch.
So gesagt so, ja er würde sich auch nicht mehr so genau erinnern, wo er dann irgendwie überall war. Seit der aus der Quarantäne raus ist. Ähm und hat halt ganz bequem ähm besonders einen Kontakt mit einer jungen Frau verschwiegen. Ähm und ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie die,
äh wie die Gesundheitsämter auf sie gekommen sind, aber die haben dann ähm gestern diese junge Frau ausfindig gemacht.
Und die war wohl definitiv enger Kontakt von ihm ähm und äh wurde getestet und,
hatte, hatte dann Covid. Und das, sie war dann eben der erste Fall von ähm einem
Fall von Covid, der im Inland übertragen worden war, weil ähm alle anderen Infektionen, die gefunden wurden in den letzten Monaten waren immer Leute, die quasi Covid aus dem Ausland mitgebracht haben und sie hat sich eben,
infiziert. Und genau, das ist das Ende dieses zweihundertdreiundfünfzig Tage Laufs.
Und äh das heißt, dass die Piloten und die Airline Crew sich nicht nochmal testen lassen muss, bevor sie losfliegt und bevor sie ankommt.
Ähm das ist so ein bisschen unklar. Ich bin tatsächlich, ich war mir auch nicht so sicher, ich bin mir
nicht ganz so sicher, wie genau die Sonderregeln sind. Also ich war eigentlich davon ausgegangen, dass sie zumindest schon noch getestet werden
und ich war auch echt überrascht davon, dass er nur drei Tage Quarantäne machen muss, weil im November wurden zwei Angestellte von Airlines, das ist eine der beiden großen Airlines in Taron, die wurden tatsächlich gefeuert,
weil sie während ihrer zehntägigen Quarantäne nach Oquer, also sich wohl mit Leuten getroffen haben, die
hat sie in ihrer Quarantäne besucht haben. Und ähm zehn Tage ist halt so eine verkürzte Quarantänezeit und ich war schon sehr überrascht, dass er nur drei machen musste. Ähm und aber das ist halt wirklich eine Sonderregelung, die wirklich nur für sehr wenige Leute zutrifft und deswegen ähm weiß ich tatsächlich nicht ganz genau, was die Regeln sind.
Und es ist aber auch davon auszugehen, dass das jetzt verschärft wird. Also ich glaube.
Die Motivation dahinter waren wohl in erster Linie wirtschaftlich, ähm um halt zum Beispiel äh so also so Cargo Flights weiter zu erlauben, ne, also,
Waren ins Ausland und umgekehrt. Und ähm ich gehe davon aus, dass die da jetzt äh ziemlich hinterher sein werden. Ähm das auch zu verschärfen, um sicher zu gehen, dass sowas nicht nochmal passiert.
Auch in in Vietnam war auch der ähm,
der neue Ausbruch wurde auch von einem Flugbegleiter verursacht, der das Virus ähm mitgebracht hat und äh sich dann nicht an die entsprechenden Quarantäne-Regeln gehalten hat.
Ja, da werden die jetzt sicherlich keinen Spaß äh verstehen damit, ne.
Nee, also das ist auch davon auszugehen, dass der Mann gefeuert wird. Ähm das muss man ganz klar sagen, ähm weil also nachdem diese beiden Flugbegleiter gefeuert wurden im November, gehe ich davon aus, dass dieser Pilot jetzt auch keinen Job mehr hat.
Oder auf absehbarer Zeit und auch jemand meinte, auch schon ähm auf Twitter heute, so der, der dieser, dieser Neuseeländer ist jetzt gerade der meistgehasste Mann in Taiwan, weil ähm und das ist natürlich auch, das muss man auch.
Darf man auch nicht aus den Augen verlieren. Es ist wirklich also viele Leute sind wirklich zurückgekommen dieses Jahr, weil wenn man
Vielleicht einen Terminesischen Pass hat und vielleicht im Ausland lebt, wenn man, wenn man jemals zurückkommen sollte, dann wäre das jetzt der richtige Moment, weil man ähm dann zum Beispiel der Katastrophe in Nordamerika oder Europa entkommen kann, wo viele Leute aus Terror an leben und arbeiten. Oder studieren.
Und das heißt, es gibt wirklich viele Leute in diesem Land, die diese zweiwöchige Quarantäne gemacht haben und die sich daran gehalten haben. Ähm ich erkenne zum Beispiel Studierende, die haben dann halt wirklich zwei Wochen in ihrem Kinderzimmer bei ihren Eltern verbracht, weil sie halt nicht, also die dürfen halt nicht mit dem Rest der Familie dann Umgang haben,
Im Zweifel haben sie dann designiertes designierte Toilette gehabt oder so. Ähm aber die sind dann wirklich nicht aus ihrem aus ihrem Kinderzimmer raus. So ähm oder in meinem Fall halt siebzehn Quadratmeter in einem Hotelzimmer. Fenster geht nicht auf,
Ich kann nicht auf den Stuhl gehen oder so und ähm das hat vierzehn Tage. Das heißt, gerade Leute, die das gemacht haben, fühlen sich halt auch total verarscht. So, also was glaubt so ein bisschen, so was glaubt dieser Mann, wer er ist?
Dass er das quasi, weil das ist, daran merkt man auch dieses halt wirklich ein,
Eine kollektive Anstrengung. So, ne, also ist wirklich, das tut man, das tut man als Gesellschaft und wenn man in Quarantäne sitzt, das hatte ich so das Gefühl und ich kenne viele andere Leute, die das auch so gesagt haben. Man hat das Gefühl, dass man etwas dazu beiträgt. Man tut seinen Teil.
Mein Hotel hat mir auch eine ganz total niedliche, so eine Urkunde,
wo sie so ähm gesagt haben, ja herzlichen Glückwunsch zu ihrem Abschluss von der ähm School of Pendemic Prevention oder so, irgendwie so, so total, so ganz niedlich, aber schon im Sinne von, wir erkennen das an, dass du jetzt was gemacht hast, das war nicht einfach und hier herzlichen Glückwunsch, wir wollen das irgendwie,
Würdigen, wenn's auch nur so eine Urkunde ist, die wir zusammen gephotoshoppt haben.
Okay.
Na dann lass uns doch einfach mal direkt bei alten weißen Männern bleiben. Ähm.
Auslöser dafür, dass wir uns ja darüber unterhalten haben, dass wir endlich mal wieder eine gemeinsame Sendung machen müssen, ist äh die Einlassungen von Herrn,
Niederrhein,
ein äh Philosoph, der irgendwie letzte Woche in der Sendung von Anne Will ausführliche Konzepte geschildert hat, wie er meinte, wie Südkorea und.
Taiwan, äh die Krise in den Griff bekommen hätten und es wäre natürlich ganz klar,
Ein Nachteil, alles was wir an Problemen in Deutschland haben, ist ein Problem des Datenschutzes und wenn wir endlich den Datenschutz über Bord werfen, dann können wir so leben,
wie in äh Taiwan und Südkorea.
Ich hab auf Twitter gesehen, dass du genau wie ich nicht unbedingt den Eindruck hast, dass an dieser Äußerung und Einschätzung sehr viel dran ist.
Insofern wie würdest du denn äh wie würdest du das denn jetzt mal als äh eine Person, die vor Ort ist und ansonsten auch sonst weiß, wovon sie redet, beurteilen.
Also ich würde mal mit einem Anekdote anfangen. Ich habe nämlich an der Freundin von mir vor ein paar Tagen die Corona-App gezeigt und erklärt. Sie meint das so was? Das ist ja mega creepy. Ähm
Also unsere total tolle Datenschutz Corona-App und so, weil ich ihr erklärt habe, ja, da wird dann die ganze Zeit getrackt, mit wem du interagierst und wen du vorbeiläufst und sie fand das total bizarr und creepy,
weil es gibt es hier nicht. Ähm ich ähm habe ja schon so ein bisschen das ist also es gibt keine App, ähm das ist äh,
Tut mir leid für das deutsche Gesundheitsministerium. Ähm in äh man muss Taiwaner Südkorea separat betrachten, glaube ich, weil die Strategien unterschiedlich sind. Ähm
das, was die Leute in Deutschland anekdotisch gehört haben, aus Taiwan, ist, dass die Quarantäne digital über, also elektronisch überwacht wird, also da wird so ein ähm äh System benutzt,
deswegen brauchten wir auch musste ich mir auch eine tervanesische SIM-Karte holen als ich angekommen bin, weil zwei Wochen lang der Standort meines Telefons überwacht wird. Ähm
Aber wirklich nur für die Quarantäne, danach ist es vorbei und die Daten werden gelöscht. Und ich habe mir zum Beispiel einfach, weil ich ähm,
so eine instinktive Paranoia noch habe, ähm habe mir eh nur eine SIM-Karte gekauft, die halt fünfzehn Tage gültig ist und danach eh deaktiviert wird. Das heißt, ähm als ich zehn Stunden aus der Quarantäne raus war, habe ich dann eine Nachricht gekriegt, die sie im deaktiviert, nicht so super, habe sie durch eine andere SIM-Karte ersetzt.
Also das heißt, das ist so der einzige Teil, wo sowas gemacht wird. Aber ähm genau, so das ist einmal die Sache mit der Quarantäne. Ähm und.
Eine Frage jetzt wenn du dir eine wenn du dir dafür eine SIM-Karte nimmst, könntest du dir ja dafür auch ein zweites Telefon nehmen. Gibt's da auch diese,
Testanrufe, also das hat man ja auch gehört, dass dann irgendwie zu äh zu irgendwelchen Zeiten,
angerufen wird und gesagt wird, so zeig mal bitte auch, dass du drangehst, dass das Telefon seit vierzehn Tagen am gleichen Ort ist, wissen wir, aber das ist ja noch kein Beweis dafür, dass du das auch.
Genau, also es variiert so ein bisschen. Ähm ich weiß, dass manche Leute da wirklich immer also so täglich Anrufe von ihren lokalen Gesundheitsämtern gekriegt haben, so wie das in Deutschland ja theoretisch eigentlich auch passieren sollte, ne. Also Leute, die ich kenne, die in Deutschland Quarantäne wahrnehmen, wurde auch gesagt, dass das Gesundheitsamt regelmäßig anruft,
Und bei mir war das so, ich habe einfach jeden Tag eine SMS gekriegt, wo ich sagen musste, so ähm wo ich einfach mit eins antworten musste, wenn ich keine Corona-Symptome hatte.
Und ich glaube, ich habe drei Mal Anrufe gekriegt. Ähm also
so eine Symptomafrage quasi jeden Tag und ähm die SMS kam aber immer jeden Morgen um zehn. Also ich habe das auch andauernd verpasst. Also ich habe regelmäßig diese SMS viel zu spät
beantwortet. Ähm und das ist aber auch in Ordnung. Ähm ich habe auch diverse Anrufe von der Seuchenbekämpfungsbehörde verpasst, weil mein Handy immer auf lautlos ist und so, aber das war auch okay,
Ähm und genau, das heißt, es ist sehr viel auch analog. Und ich glaube, man muss dazu auch sagen, also bei Quarantäne ist ja für zwei verschiedene Zwecke. Der eine Zweck ist, ähm weil Timo Zero Covid hat,
möchte man an der Grenze verhindern, dass die Leute reinkommen
So, das ist aber, also ich habe ja eben schon auch sehr detailliert diesen Prozess beschrieben. Das heißt, da ist ganz viel passiert drumherum, um diese Quarantäne, um sicher zu, um das überhaupt zu ermöglichen. Das heißt, diese elektronische Bewachung ist nur ein ganz kleiner Teil,
Aber dazu kommt ja noch diese ganze Infrastruktur am Flughafen, mit den Taxis.
Mit mit den Leuten im Hotel, die mir zum Beispiel dreimal am Tag meine Mahlzeiten an die Tür hängen, damit ich wirklich nicht rausgehen muss und alles quasi da habe so. Also das ist so die.
Die Temperaturmessung.
Die Temperaturmessung, die ich auch selber mache, aber die ich dann über WhatsApp quasi einfach der ähm für eine bestimmte DSGVO verletzen in Deutschland oder Hipper in den USA
aber wo ich dann halt meine Temperatur dem Hotel schicke, zweimal pro Tag. Das ist halt auch nicht das überprüft halt auch keiner, ob das wirklich meine Trabatur ist, aber ist eher so das ganze System Nadelstich quasi so ein bisschen so und macht so, okay, mach mal hier, mach mal da. Und es geht halt um Risikominimierung. Und so einfach wie möglich zu machen im Wesentlichen. Und ich finde es auch
Also meine Erfahrung war auch dadurch, dass,
Die Quarantäne so strikt ist, wird dir auch eigentlich, wenn dir auch deine ganzen Entscheidungen abgenommen. Ich habe das Gefühl, auch wenn Leute in Deutschland Quarantäne sind, weil diese ganze Eigenverantwortungssache so hochgeschrieben hochgehalten wird. Ist oft so ein bisschen so, hm, ja
kann ich jetzt doch noch spazieren gehen? Ja, okay, vielleicht kann ich noch spazieren gehen. Man überlegt sich das dann irgendwie noch so,
weil das dann auf die einzelne Person abgeschoben wird so ein bisschen und bei mir war das halt so, okay, ich kann halt nicht raus.
Ähm aber das ist halt eben nicht, also diese diese elektronische Überwachung ist ein ganz kleiner Teil davon.
Würdest du denn diese Maßnahmen, also ich denke, also ich so mal nach deutscher Übersetzung wäre das halt eine elektronische Fußfessel, ne? Dein Handy wird zum zur Verräterin gegen dich. Ähm durch so eine App dadrauf und.
Keine App. Das ist wichtig. Wir müssen aufhören, davon von Apps zu reden.
Das geht auch mit das geht auch mit Brick Thones, die benutzen das, die arbeiten mit den die ich die tavenesische Regierung arbeitet mit den Telekom Telefon also den Telefon Providern zusammen und die benutzen.
Okay, also noch ein Unsinn, den Niederrhein behauptet hat. Er hat nämlich gesagt, äh die, also das Zitat war ähm
Das wurde in den Medien so wiedergegeben, dass viel genauere GPS, ja, also mit dem die Location viel genauer festgestellt werden würde als mit Bluetooth,
also auf viele Weisen falsch ist. Erstens, weil GPS nicht so genaue Location
Feststellung ermöglicht wie Bluetooth Low Energy Beekens und zweitens weil GPS nicht verwendet wurde. Also so ein ein.
Ein Satz, der quasi sowieso schon falsch ist, aber dann auch nochmal falsch ist.
Genau, also es wird, es läuft, glaube ich, über die Funkzellen, aber ich wir können auch ähm Mary Hey hat einen sehr guten Artikel für Quads über das System geschrieben. Den können wir dann in den Shownote sicher verlinken.
Das wäre super. Also es geht im Prinzip aber dann muss ich trotzdem sagen, ne, wenn man jetzt mal also GPS wegnimmt, dann heißt das ähm also über die ähm,
in die dein Mobiltelefon eingewählt ist, wird es ähm,
triaguliert. Du kannst dadurch relativ genau eine äh Positionsbestimmung machen,
aber im Zweifelsfall sagen wir mal, wenn du jetzt im, im Haus auf und ab gehen würdest oder sowas oder mal die Straße fünfzig Meter runter, da würde ich mich noch halbwegs sicher fühlen, nicht erwischt zu werden.
Ähm.
Ich glaube glaube trotzdem, dass sowas mit äh mit deutschen Leuten nicht zu machen wäre, dass das Telefon gegen sie zu dressieren.
Genau, aber ich finde, ich würde dort erst noch auf den zweiten Zweck der Quarantäne eingehen und dann kann ich nämlich auch sagen, warum ich glaube, dass es nicht kein wesentlicher Teil ist. Weil der andere Zweck der Quarantäne ist ja bei dem Contact-Tracing, also im März haben wir zwischenzeitlich mal über ähm,
Trace Test Isolate gesprochen als Prinzip, also so nachverfolgen, ähm testen lassen und isolieren,
Das ist dann komplett untergegangen, wenn wir mittlerweile ein Punkt sind, wo die Gesundheitsämter das nicht mehr machen
können. Aber so so wie das in Taiwan wird das halt praktiziert. Und ähm die Quarantäne war ein ganz wichtiger Teil dessen wie Thaiwan
ähm Anfang des Jahres die Ausbrüche unterdrückt hat, weil sie wenn es einen positiven Fall gab, also erstmal, wenn wir einen Verdacht auf Corona hat, wird die Person erstmal in die Quarantäne geschickt. So,
bis das Testergebnis da ist. Sobald das Testergebnis da ist, ähm wird äh wird die Person
Wenn sie positiv getestet wurde, werden sämtliche engen Kontakt wenn relevante Kontakte identifiziert und die werden wiederum auch in Quarantäne geschickt.
Und dann werden auch getestet und jede Person die positiv getestet wird das heißt also wenn ein positiver Test passiert dann löst es quasi aus,
Kontakt nach Verfolgung und die Person selber muss ins Krankenhaus, weil wenn man Corona hat, dann hängt man nicht zu Hause rum in Timer, man wird ins Krankenhaus, auf eine Isolationsstation geschickt, egal ob man Symptome hat oder nicht,
und da wird man, wird dann halt sicher gegangen, dass die Person halt auch erst wieder rauskommt, wenn sie quasi zwei irgendwie zwei Mal negativ getestet wurde oder so was.
Und dieser Kontakt nach Verfolgungsprozess, da gibt es irgendwie diese Idee, dass das irgendwie auch ganz elektronisch funktioniert. Ich habe im April mit jemandem gesprochen, der für die tavenesische Seuchenbekämpfungsbehörde arbeitet, das heißt
Ich habe, glaube ich, direktere Informationen als die meisten Leute, die zu diesem Thema in Deutschland reden und die solchen Bekanntungsförder hat gesagt, das ist Quatsch, das elektronisch zu machen, weil das nichts bringt.
Außerdem haben sie gesagt, die Erfahrung ähm also dieser dieser dieser Arzt, mit dem ich gesprochen habe. Er hat auch gesagt, die Erfahrung in eine Kontaktnachverfolgung ist, ähm dass die Kontakte, die wirklich infiziert wurden, so eng sind, ähm dass es auch nicht.
Irgendwie relevant wäre groß rauszufinden, ob die Person zu irgendwelchen ähm zu irgendwelchen ähm Einkaufszentren gegangen ist oder so was,
weil die Leute das meistens eher wissen und dass er halt, er hat halt wirklich betont, er sagt, das kann man nicht automatisieren und man kann das auch nicht einfach ersetzen, weil das ein wichtiger Skill ist, da gehen dann halt Leute hin, die haben A, epidemiologisches Wissen
und B haben sie quasi social skills. Das heißt, die gehen hin und unterhalten sich mit den Leuten, ähm die infiziert wurden
und ähm müssen dann quasi nicht nur mit denen irgendwie reden und so ein bisschen so Rapport aufbauen, sondern auch dann gleichzeitig die ganze Zeit evaluieren, welche von diesen Personen ist jetzt eventuell ähm
Also hat ein hohes Risiko auch äh sich mit Covid infiziert zu haben. Es gibt, glaube ich, theoretisch die Möglichkeit, ähm
nach im Nachhinein auf GPS-Daten zuzugreifen. Ich glaube aber, dass es um dass es tatsächlich ein bisschen unklar gerade. Weil ähm zwischenzeitlich,
haben mal Leute gesagt, das ginge, aber als ich mit den also als ich mit den Menschen von der solchen Bekämpfungshörde gesprochen habe und das war ja nachdem der letzte Lokal übertragene Fall schon durch war, meinte er, äh wüsste nichts davon, dass es irgendwie mal benutzt worden sei.
Ähm und dass der Punkt ist, ich glaube, was man da verstehen muss, ähm das heißt, bei der Kontaktnachverfolgung ist irgendwie sind irgendwelche elektronischen Sachen.
In Taiwan wurden sie nicht benutzt, sie haben nicht dazu beigetragen. Stattdessen war wichtig, ähm dass man ganz schnell die Leute testen lassen kann und dass man die Testergebnisse schnell bekommt,
in dem Moment, in dem man Testergebnis hat, kann man die anderen Leute finden und isolieren, ähm um sicher zu gehen, dass sie niemanden anstecken, falls sie Covid haben. Und so hat Taiwan covid unterdrückt.
Und das würde auch, und deswegen ist diese ganze Sache mit der Fußfessel, das ist eine total müßige Diskussion,
Weil wenn wir dieses ganze System drum herum hätten, uns unser einziges Problem wäre, ob die Leute sich in ihre Quarantäne halten oder nicht.
Dann könnten auch die Gesundheitsämter, keine Ahnung, dann rufen halt die Gesundheitsämter alle vier Stunden an oder so,
oder es kommt halt mal jemand vom Gesundheitsamt vorbei, ich weiß es nicht. Aber diese also diese elektronische Fußfessel, diese Überwachung ist ein winzig kleiner Teil und die bringt dir auch nichts, wenn,
Kontaktverfolgung nicht hinterher kommt, die bringt dir nichts, wenn die Testergebnisse drei Tage dauern, die bringt dir nichts, wenn du die Kontakte nicht findest. Also da Heck steckt ein riesiges System hinter, was nichts mit Datenschutz, also natürlich Datenschutz, weil sie mit den Leuten reden und diese Informationen kriegen müssen, aber das ist halt,
das ist eine andere.
Aber nichts mit mit nichts mit Datensammlung.
Genau, nix mit Smart City, nichts mit KI, dies das alles, das ist alles Quatsch.
Wenn jetzt diese Kontaktverfolgung stattfindet, du hast das gerade eher so am am Rande gesagt, äh der Klang raus, das findet also mehr oder weniger durch ein Gespräch mit den Menschen statt. Hm spielt dabei sowas wie ähm,
hier Besucherinnenerfassung in gastronomischen Einrichtungen eine Rolle, was ja hier auch das das große Thema ist, ne?
Ja, habe ich nicht drüber geredet mit den Leuten damals. Also das kam das kam nicht auf. Ähm ich weiß, dass jetzt hier also jetzt grade wird hier nix irgendwie,
Wenn ihr keine Kontaktdaten abgefragt, wenn ich irgendwie ins Restaurant gehe oder so.
Aber man muss natürlich gucken was ob sie jetzt die Maßnahmen nochmal verschärfen wenn es kommt ein bisschen darauf an ob sie diesen Fall jetzt unter Kontrolle kriegen, ne? Weil die große Frage ist.
Sind schon mal gute Voraussetzungen. Ähm das sieht man auch in diesem Fall von diesem neuisierenden Piloten ganz gut. Weil A, sie wissen, wo die Infektion herkam. Das heißt, sie wissen
Quasi Passion Zero ist und können, wenn sie, wenn er kooperiert und sie seine ganzen Kontakte finden, dann können sie die alle isolieren. Denn im Zweifel gehen sie noch ein Stück weiter und ihr Özilin die anderen Leute auch noch,
und man sieht auch daran, wie schnell sie arbeiten, dass ähm gestern wurde diese ähm Frau gefunden, die sich bei ihm infiziert hat
Und heute haben sie schon gesagt, ja, wir haben hundertsiebenundsechzig Kontakte von ihr identifiziert. Dreizehn von denen sind enge Kontakte, die sind jetzt in Quarantäne. Die anderen müssen alle so
ihre eigene Gesundheit überwachen, aber alle hundertsiebenundsechzig werden getestet. Es wurde auch direkt gesagt, so viele wurden schon getestet, so viele warten gerade aufs Testergebnis, die anderen werden heute noch getestet. Ähm das heißt, da ist ganz viel, da steckt ganz viel Infrastruktur dahinter
ähm um die ganzen Fälle direkt unter Kontrolle zu kriegen. Das heißt, die Voraussetzungen sind relativ gut, um das unter Kontrolle zu kriegen, aber.
Man kann, man weiß es nicht, also.
Und jetzt muss man natürlich sagen, so das könnten wir uns äh in Deutschland auch leisten, wenn wir irgendwie solche geringen Inzidenzzahlen hätten wie,
Taiwan, aber wenn man äh in Deutschland eben in dieser Situation ist mit irgendwie mehreren zehntausend Infektionen und diesem
Begriff, den Christian Drosten im Podcast mal als Perkulation eingeführt hat, ist sicherlich ein kompletter Standardbegriff solcher Diskussionen, die seit längerer Zeit geführt werden, aber die wir ja jetzt erst seit kurzer Zeit verfolgen,
Und das war das mit dem Kaffeefilter, wo er nämlich sagt, ne, wenn man äh also Kaffee klassischer,
Filterkaffee, wenn man dann nur so ein bisschen Wasser reintut, dann quillt das erstmal auf und bis der Punkt kommt, dass Wasser wirklich auch durch den Kaffeefilter durchfließt, muss erstmal der gesamte Kaffee dadrin.
Aufgequäulen sein und feucht sein. Und was jetzt in Deutschland nach dieser Beschreibung eben passiert ist, ist, wir haben dadurch, dass wir zwar niedrige, aber beständige Inzidenz überall hatten,
letztendlich dazu geführt, dass wir am laufenden Band irgendwo aufploppen haben und nicht mehr so.
Traumhafte Fälle, wo du weißt, das ist der Patient, da muss ich jetzt mal hunderte Kontakte anrufen, da muss ich jetzt mal dreizehn isolieren, aber ich habe auch im Prinzip die gesamte Energie meiner,
Gesundheitskapazität des Landes, um sie da drauf zu werfen, während wir in Deutschland in der Situation sind, dass sie erläutern,
wenn du dich beim Gesundheitsamt meldest und sagst, ich habe hier Covid-Symptome, dass die sagen, sorry, gibt gerade keine Tests, bleiben sie mal zu Hause.
Oder dass sie, wenn du in der Schule ähm Kinder irgendwie wegen Verdachtsfall oder positiven Test isoliert werden, sagen, ja okay, der.
Der Kevin, der daneben gesessen hat, der muss jetzt auch zwei Tage zu Hause bleiben, ob er Symptome hat, aber die Tina, die neben dem Kevin gesessen hat, die darf munter weiterhin zur Schule, ne, also in Deutschland können wir uns ja diese Anstrengungen.
Überhaupt nicht mehr leisten. Da scheint mir der Unterschied zu sein. Wahrscheinlich könnte Taylon das bei unserer Inzidenz äh auch nicht mehr äh auf die Kette kriegen.
Nee, tatsächlich hat mir auch also der ähm der Angestellte von der solchen Bekämpfungsbehörde hier, mit dem ich gesprochen habe,
vor ein paar Monaten, der hat mir auch gesagt, sie haben am Anfang versucht, also sie wollten richtig hardcore rangehen und gesagt, jeden Verdachtsfall,
nachverfolgen. Also sie quasi versucht haben, direkt Kontakt nachverfolgen für jeden Verdacht auf Covid-Nurd zu machen. Aber Taimann hat halt auch Winter, ähm also das ist halt nicht ganz so kalt wie in Deutschland, aber auch ähm.
Erkältungssaison und alles gehabt und da hatten sie teils bis zu tausend Verdachtsfälle auf Covid pro Tag und da mussten sie sehr schnell auch
sagen, okay, wir können das nicht leisten, wir haben die Kapazitäten nicht, um pro Tag tausend Leute zu contact racen. Und deswegen haben sie eben, dass sie, daran sieht man auch, dass ähm,
Ein wichtiger Teil der Antwort hier auch nicht nur,
elektronisch war, sondern dass es auch darum geht, wie schnell Behörden reagieren können, weil die solchen Bekämpfungs eben gesagt hat, okay, dann müssen wir diesen, diesen Prozesspunkt, wo jemand getestet wird und wie schnell das Ergebnis,
kommt, das müssen wir optimieren und dann haben sie eben versucht, diesen ähm die Testergebnisprozess zu optimieren. Ich glaube, er meinte dann, sie waren irgendwann auf unter zwölf Stunden für jeden Test, aber oft innerhalb von wenigen einstelligen Stunden.
Und sie haben dann das halt forciert und dann nur noch Kontakt nach Verfolgung für bestätigte Fälle gemacht, um Ressourcen zu schonen.
Aber es war halt eine ziemlich gezieltes wir können nicht die Kontaktnachverfolgung für so viele Fälle machen und das heißt auch wir wissen, wenn Taiwan so viele Fälle haben würde, würde die Strategie auch nicht mehr funktionieren und sie müssten's wieder anpassen.
Das ist ganz klar.
Also kam es dazu oder also der das einzige, was ihn ja dann zur als Möglichkeit zur Wahl stünde, wäre ja im Zweifelsfall äh in einen harten Lockdown wieder zu gehen. Was sie ja, wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe, auch schon äh also einmal gemacht hatten, mit Schulen schließen.
Sie nie. Genau, sie hatten Schulen zu, aber es gab nie einen harten Lockdown. Ähm hier, also.
Okay, das ist jetzt also die Frage, das ist für in Deutschland das Härteste, was es gibt, ja, dass man die Schule geschlossen wird, da da wird ja hier nur noch mit Hart und Hertha und,
von vorne und von hinten äh argumentiert, weil wir irgendwie für unsere Lockdown-Lights Mediums und ähm,
ähm null Prozent Fett irgendwie keine Begriffe mehr finden
Ähm Korea habe ich mich auch nochmal ein bisschen mit auseinandergesetzt, also Südkorea hatten, wenn ich das richtig verstehe im August nochmal so einen kleinen Peek.
Der von religiösen Fundamentalisten.
Äh irgendwie ausging oder auf die denen in die Schuhe geschoben wurde, die da irgendwelche politischen Demonstrationen ohne Maske gemacht haben und die Reaktion, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, du korrigierst mich, weil du das, glaube ich, besser aufm Schirm hast, ist, sie haben dann,
ähm mit mit starken Restriktionen sofort wieder reagiert, um die Situation wieder ähm beherrschbar zu machen.
Ja, so habe ich das auch auf dem Schirm, aber Südkorea ist auch nicht. Da kenne ich mich deutlich weniger aus, als ähm in Taiwan, weil ich auch in Taiwan gelebt habe und viel viele Kontakte habe und das ist halt schon der Unterschied zwischen chinesischsprachiger Welt und,
chinesische Sprache ist. Ähm was ich aber auch, was man dazu noch sagen muss, ist, dass Korea tatsächlich Südkorea das Land ist, dass ähm wahrscheinlich
invasivste Strategie hat, was Datenschutz angeht
Ähm von der ich weiß. Bei den Südkorea wird durchaus, wenn jemand bestätigt wird als covid-positiv, ähm dann ähm sind die äh Leute, die Kontakt nach Verfolgung machen, definitiv ermächtigt, zum Beispiel auf Kreditkarten, Daten zuzugreifen.
Oder auf ähm Bewegungsdaten ähm rückblickend. Das wird auch genutzt
auf jeden Fall. Also da wird das auf jeden Fall gemacht. Und da sitzt dann halt jemand vom Gesundheitsamt und ähm anstatt nur die Sachen aus diesem Interview zu nutzen, ähm kann die Person dann halt noch auf diese anderen Seiten zugreifen.
Und ich hab mit einem also ich spreche kein Koreanisch ich hab mit dem Journalisten gesprochen der mit ein paar von diesen Gesundheitsämtern gesprochen hat und der die haben ihm halt gesagt das ist halt was das
vor allem für so Erinnerungslücken hilft, weil die Leute halt oft nicht mehr wissen, was sie irgendwie gemacht haben oder so. Und das ist, glaube ich, so das Beispiel, wo man sagt, dass am ehesten noch invasives Datenschutz angeht
und das auch am ehesten noch irgendwie schwierig äh aus der aus der Perspektive würde ich sagen. Aber das Interessante ist auch, dass die Süd, selbst wenn ich mit wenn ich mit Leuten in China gesprochen habe, weil in China läuft Kontakt nach Verfolgung wesentlichen so wie in Taiwan. Da sagen mir die Leute in China so
aber gucken wir mal die Koreaner an, was die da machen, das ist wirklich problematisch mit Datenschutz. Ähm.
Und trotzdem scheint der Erfolg ähm im August.
In meinen Augen darauf, am ehesten damit erklärbar zu sein, dass sie eben Restriktionen äh ähm gezogen haben und nicht unbedingt damit, dass sie irgendwie,
Datenschutz so sehr verletzt haben. Genau diese Lockdowns will aber dieser ähm Herr Rummelin nicht haben.
Ja, also das wird ja immer gesagt, also das das haben wir hier von von allen Experten ähm seien es irgendwie,
sei es die bisher wenig zur Lösung beigetragen haben, aber viel gesagt haben, dass sie eben
immer sagen ein Lockdown kann keine Lösung sein. Eine Alternativlösung, die irgendwo auf diesem Planeten mal ähm vorzeigbare Erfolge äh präsentiert hätte, zeigen sie aber nicht. So.
Insofern finde ich das tatsächlich ähm ja, ich finde das sehr schwierig, weil,
Philosophen in meinen Augen auch wirklich nur dann zu gebrauchen sind, wenn sich ihre Gedanken grob an den Bedingungen der Realität orientieren und da kiffen hilft halt nicht dabei, ne? Also da muss man ganz.
Kurzer Zwischeneinwurf nicht, dass uns auch gleich wieder vorgeworfen wird. Wir würden uns nicht an der Realität orientieren, weil du meintest irgendwie äh.
Korea und so weiter alles schon wieder vorbei, also seit drei Wochen geht's da wild ab. Also die haben sozusagen derzeit die allerhöchsten Zahlen, äh das übersteigt auch das, was sie im März äh maximal hatten, bereits
und äh derzeit ist noch nicht zu sehen, dass sie das irgendwie in den Griff kriegen. Also irgendwas ist ihnen auch gerade aus dem Ruder gelaufen. Nur, dass die Zahlen natürlich noch nicht ansatzweise da sind, wo sie bei uns sind. Von daher ähm kann man das schwer vergleichen, aber,
südkoreanische Verhältnisse befinden die sich sozusagen gerade in so einem exponentiellen, also.
Generell befinden sich im exponentiellen Wachstum und für südkoreanische Verhältnisse, müssen sie jetzt erstmal zeigen, dass ihre alten Methoden jetzt auch wieder schnell greifen.
Danke Tim, dass du das sagst. Ich würde vor allem jetzt einfach mal sagen, also Südkorea leidet einfach an viel zu hohem Datenschutz. Das sieht man an dieser steigenden Kurve,
Ja, also das ist ja eindeutig zu sehen. Äh danke, dass du das nochmal zur Sprache bringst,
mal gucken, was man da noch, also da wird man nachher sehen, wie Südkorea an seinen Datenschutzvorstellungen jetzt hier krepiert, na? Das kann man sich jetzt wieder anschauen. So ist doch ganz eindeutig die Realität.
Ich glaube, ein großes Problem bei dieser ganzen Sache ist halt auch, dass Leute halt dann irgendwelche Sachen über Asien sagen, ohne sich wirklich damit auseinanderzusetzen,
Also das ist halt im März schon ein riesen Problem gewesen. Das hat mich da schon total aufgeregt. Dass dann halt irgendwelche Sachen über irgendwie Smart Cities oder irgendwie diese total genaue Funkzellen bla in Asien oder so um sich herum geworfen werden. Das sind halt
Ich habe das Gefühl, das sind oft eher so ein bisschen die Fantasien von irgendwelchen Leuten, die sich das so ein bisschen so vorstellen und sich so im Kopf so überlegen, boah, das funktioniert bestimmt voll gut. Sie haben irgendwas
Überwachung in Asien gehört ähm und sagen dann, ah ja, genau, hier Asien macht voll gut Corona. Asiaten, denen ist Datenschutz ja eh egal. Und das das kommt dann in so einer ganz komischen,
Dystopie zusammen und das ist so ein bisschen so dieses Asien darf halt kein richtiger Ort sein, sondern das ist ein Ort, auf den irgendwie so Dystopien und Fantasien projiziert werden. Und das wiederum kommt dann jetzt zurück in den Diskurs in Deutschland. Und ich glaube, es ist wirklich
sehr wichtig, ähm dass man sich ähm,
Wenn man von diesen Ländern lernen möchte, nicht mit irgendwelchen Fantasien auseinandersetzt, sondern wirklich mit den Leuten spricht, diese Arbeit machen ähm und sich damit auseinandersetzt, das wirklich vor Ort passiert,
und gleichzeitig ist es aber natürlich auch so, dass Deutschland, das muss man einfach auch ganz klar sagen, hat's einfach versemmelt. Ähm und wir sind jetzt in Deutschland,
Ist jetzt nicht an einem Punkt, an dem es groß von Asien gerade lernen kann, weil es erstmal an einen Punkt kommen muss, wo es diese ganzen Strategien überhaupt erst anwenden kann. Und das ist einfach, ob das die große Sache. Weil es gibt, also in der ganzen Pandemie der einzige, das einzige Land, das einmal richtig Land unterhatte, war China.
Und die haben dann halt einmal das Land zugemacht und zwar so richtig,
und haben somit aus unter Kontrolle bekommen, aber es war auf auf einem ganz anderen Niveau, als es in Deutschland gerade ist. Deswegen ist die wichtige, die große Frage ist halt,
wie man an so einem Punkt kommt, an dem man diese erfolgreichen Strategien zur Unterdrückung des Virus nutzen kann.
Und da gab's ja gerade zum Beispiel dieses Papier von diversen Virologinnen und ähm Epidemiologen, wo auch glaube ich Sandra Zieseck oder so noch mit unterschrieben haben, die halt genau das sagen, die sagen, wir brauchen einen Lockdown, der muss hart sein, damit wir an einen Punkt kommen, wo wir es kontrollieren können.
Weil dann kann man wie ähm zum Beispiel in also Südkorea hatte halt sehr lange ziemlich normales Leben und es gab einen Ausbruch, ähm der zum Beispiel in der Clubszene auch ähm war, weil die Leute halt feiern gehen konnten,
das soweit unter Kontrolle war. Und dann hatte man halt immer wieder diese Ausbrüche, die man lange unter Kontrolle bekommen hat. Und jetzt leider nicht mehr und ich äh.
Wünsche ihnen sehr, dass sie das, ich hoffe, dass sie das einigermaßen hinbekommen, weil in Korea werden die Südkorea, wenn die Krankenhausbetten schon knapp, das ähm ist äh keine gute Situation gerade.
So schnell kann einem die Situation also auch wieder entgleiten mit egal welchen
jetzt äh vorgegangen wurde, es sei denn, äh egal, ob es Chinesische, deutsche oder taiwanesische sind, also das ne, das Risiko ähm bedroht ja, Taiwan auch jeden Tag.
Und ähm entsprechend erfordert es eben auch jeden Tag große Anstrengungen, diese diese Fallzahlen so niedrig zu halten.
Eine Sache, die mir noch aufgefallen ist, es gab in Teilen guten Artikel zu dem Thema, die Leute in Korea oder Hongkong sind auch müde, die haben auch keinen Bock mehr, obwohl diese ganzen Restriktionen die ganze Zeit ziemlich low level waren. Und
Entsprechend lässt im Zweifel auch
so ein bisschen nach. Im Zweifel machen die Leute vielleicht weniger harte Sachen mit als noch vor ein paar Monaten. Ähm und aber trotzdem, also das ist so diese Müdigkeit ist nicht unbedingt nur eine Funktion dessen, wie locker diese Maßnahmen waren und diese Müdigkeit und diese Erschöpfung kommt halt einfach generell,
so ein bisschen aus auch auch in diesen Orten, wo die Restriktionen nie so wirklich krass waren. Ähm,
Und ich glaube, das ist auch eine wichtige Lehre für Deutschland, also vielleicht zumindest für die Zukunft, ähm dass man sich nicht irgendwie mit durch den Lockdown-Light-Sachen unbedingt,
sowas durch retten kann, weil die Leute dann einfach trotzdem irgendwann keinen Bock mehr haben und halt keine Energie mehr. Und das sieht man jetzt auch durchaus in Asien.
Vielleicht nochmal eine andere Sache ähm ich habe ja so ein bisschen den ein, also erstmal kann man, glaube ich, auch zusammenfassend sagen.
Es ist, glaube ich, grundsätzlich unangemessen zu sagen, weil diese eine Strategie befolgt wurde oder diese eine Strategie nicht befolgt wurde,
deswegen ist alles scheiße. Ja, also äh Länder sind sehr unterschiedlich. Länder äh mögen sehr erfolgreich sein. In dem einen Bereich, aber
fehlen, dann aus kulturellen oder politischen Gründen in einem anderen Bereich und irgendwas läuft einem immer irgendwie aus dem Ruder und ein paar haben vielleicht auch einfach nur mehr Glück
Ja, also vielleicht ist es sozusagen auch nochmal ein Glücksfaktor in Taiwan und ein Glücksfaktor in Neuseeland. Und äh wir wissen nicht, ob
nicht äh durch irgendeine.
Oder durch irgendeinen äh Angriffsvektor, den man jetzt sozusagen noch übersehen hat, der bisher noch nicht so eine große Rolle gehabt hat, ob nicht auch deren Haus irgendwann wieder umkippt.
Ähm was allerdings jetzt in Deutschland so ein bisschen mich ins Grübeln gebracht hat, war so diese Unfähigkeit zu einem politischen Konsens zu kommen ähm.
Meiner Auffassung nach ein wenig ausgelöst durch das föderale System, ne? Wir haben ja sozusagen diese gesamten Gesundheitsmaßnahmen auf Länderebene und obwohl es äh auf Bundesregierungsebene äh sehr wohl schon so die Bereitschaft gab,
schneller zu handeln, ja, wurde es dann eben ausgebremst äh auf föderaler Ebene. Ähm wie,
Ist denn das zum Beispiel in Taiwan? Ist das sozusagen, ist die äh alleinige Entscheidungsmacht
dort ähm äh auf zentraler Regierungsebene oder gibt's da,
im Prinzip auch noch so eine föderale Aufteilung, die dem theoretisch hätte in die Quere kommen können.
Also eine Sache, die mir sehr stark aufgefallen ist, schon auch seit Monaten ist, dass es in Taiwan viel weniger politisiert ist, diese ganze Sache. Ähm also weil die.
Die Regierung oder die solchen Bekämpfungsbehörde hat im Januar,
das Central Epidemic Center, also das zentrale Epidemie-Kommandozentrum aktiviert, das ist so 'ne Institution, die quasi so innerhalb acht Stellung existiert.
Das ist dann quasi eine eine zentrale Stelle, die diese ganze Sache in ganz Taiwan koordiniert. Das heißt, ähm da haben die Politiker innen irgendwie gar nichts mehr mit zu tun, sondern das ist quasi eine Behörde, also
Diese Behörde ist von fachlich kompetenten Menschen mit, die irgendwie geleitet. Ähm und ich glaube, da
Gesundheitsminister kommentiert schon auch noch Sachen, aber viel von diesen ganzen die meisten Sachen, das läuft alles über diese Seuchenbekämpfungsbehörde.
Und auch diese ganzen es gibt so ein tägliches Briefing, so eine tägliche Pressekonferenz. Es ich saß gestern in so einem Restaurant, habe Nudeln gegessen und dann lief auch diese Pressekonferenz von einer solchen Bekämpfungsbehörde im Fernsehen. Die Leute gucken das wirklich,
und die, die machen halt eigentlich, die geben auch solche Sachen dann raus, die sagen, na das sind die neuen Maßnahmen so und so,
Ähm das heißt, das ist, glaube ich, schon ein großer Unterschied, dass ich das Gefühl habe, dass ähm in Deutschland ist ja immer, wird immer so gesagt, ja die.
Wissenschaft kann irgendwie nur beraten sein und kann nicht sagen, was entschieden wird. Und man merkt, glaube ich, in Taiwan, dass ähm im Zweifel mehr ähm,
und auch mehr Macht dann schon einer Behörde gegeben wird oder einer Regierungsinstitution, die fachlich wirklich dafür ausgebildet ist und dafür existiert, um Epidemien zu bekämpfen. Ähm.
Und das da kann man da nicht drüber streiten, wie gut man das findet.
Ähm das ist kein keine Frage. Ähm aber es bedeutet eben auch, dass es ein ziemlich gutes, konsistentes Messaging gibt ähm und nicht so ein, also so was wie so ein so ein Söderlasche, Zweikampf oder so, wie wir das im März hatten oder so was, das ähm habe ich hier noch nicht so mit.
Ist die Frage, ob das auch noch so greifen würde äh in dem Moment, wo sie wirklich mal Maßnahmen beschließen würden, die dann die wirtschaftliche Tätigkeit auch nennenswert einschränkt?
Genau, das ist die große Frage und das ist, glaube ich, auch was, was man gerne übersieht, dass in Taiwan ähm bisher einfach noch nie so was also wobei man sagen muss, wer stark leitet, leitet es die Tourismus in Ostriemen
Also es gibt einige Teile in Taipeh
wo jetzt reihenweise Restaurants zumachen, weil das einfach Orte sind, die besonders von Touristinnen irgendwie besucht werden. Ähm und die leiden wirklich. Ähm also das muss man echt sagen. Und es gibt natürlich auch eine ähm Oppositionspartei.
Die auch versucht irgendwie
politisches Kapital rauszuschlagen. Ähm ich habe das selber noch nicht äh nachgelesen, aber ein Freund von mir, der auch sehr gut informiert ist über terminesische Politik, hat neulich noch erzählt, es gab so einen Punkt, wo die Opposition versucht hat sozusagen, das Problem, das ist, dass wir nicht genug nicht genug testen
Wir haben krasse Coronaausbrüche, wir wissen das nur nicht. Und dann hat aber, die solche Bekämpfungsbehörde gesagt, Leute, die haben so wenig Fälle,
Wenn wir jetzt die ganze Bevölkerung testen, sind allein die falsch Positiven, so viele, dass es unser Gesundheitssystem ähm so,
überstürmen wird. Und dann können dann dann kommen wir wirklich nicht mehr klar. Deswegen können wir nicht diese Massentest machen. Wir müssen weiter gezielt testen. Ähm sie dann hat wohl also,
Ich habe die genauen Details nicht, aber irgendjemand, also in irgendeinem, irgendeiner Stadt haben sie dann versucht, viele Leute zu testen, haben dann festgestellt, oh Scheiße, wir kriegen irgendwie.
Viele Fälle, die dann gar nicht Corona haben und okay, vielleicht lassen wir es einfach. Das ist dann irgendwie so ein bisschen in der Versenkung verschwunden. Also es gab so einen Versuch, das zu politisieren. Ähm aber es ist eigentlich ziemlich gescheitert. Und so die letzten Monate über war eigentlich das große politische Streitthema. Ähm da ging es um äh Schweinefleischimporte aus den USA mit irgendwelchen Zusätzen, die die Opposition nicht gut findet. Und
die die Regierung hier durchdrücken muss. Also das ist gar kein, jetzt ist es halt kein Streitpunkt mehr, aber wie du sagst, das stimmt auch, also die Leute, die die einzigen Wirtschaftshalte, die leiden, ist halt die der Tourismus und andere,
haben bisher noch nicht gelitten.
Aber das mit dem Tourismus betrifft ja sozusagen die internationalen Tourismus, nicht den nicht den nationalen Tourismus, oder?
Genau, aber Tairan ist halt schon, also die das kommt halt viel Tourismus aus ähm Korea und Japan zum Beispiel.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja jetzt nichts, was Taiwan ändern könnte, dadurch, dass sie irgendwas anders machen, kommen ja nicht automatisch mehr äh Touristen rein.
Doch sie könnten wieder Visa rausgeben und Leute wieder reinlassen. Also man kann ja gerade nicht einfach auf Touristen, wie so ein Nachteil. Und wenn man zwei Wochen Quarantäne machen, selbst wenn man Visa kriegen würde, aber dann noch zwei Wochen Quarantäne auf eigene Kosten machen muss. Es fehlen, glaube ich, nicht so viele Leute zu Besuch kommen.
Quarantäne am Strand. Und äh noch eine kurze Anmerkung ähm diese Aussage, falsch positive würden das Gesundheitssystem überlassen, verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz, weil die werden ja nicht automatisch krank, dadurch dass man sie testet.
Nee, ich glaube, die ähm das Argument war, glaube ich, dass ähm wenn zu viele positiv sind, äh positiv getestet werden, die eigentlich gar kein Corona haben. Ähm das sind zu viele, dass die Leute, also weil gerade hier ist es ja so, dass wenn jemand positiv geleistet wird, dass die Person ins Krankenhaus kommt. Ähm also es hätte.
Und es wäre dann halt schwierig, wenn man das Problem ist, man hat dann im Zweifel so und so so viel Neues.
So weil die dann quasi im Krankenhaus isoliert werden, was bei uns ja überhaupt nicht mehr der.
Genau, beim, also weil das Protokoll wird, genau, das ist halt in Deutschland ja auch unmöglich, weil man einfach auf einem Niveau ist von den Fällen. Das ist einfach, das sind ja nicht machbar. Aber das ist halt dann so viel Neues verursacht, dass man mit diesen wirklich positiven Fällen nicht mehr vernünftig umgehen kann.
Ja okay, verstehe.
Aber wo ich auch aus Lisa, das muss ich auch noch mal nachlesen, weil ähm ich habe dann nur noch andere Leute gehört, die meinten, hä, eigentlich gibt's bei PCs keine falsch Positiven. Also ich weiß nicht genau, was da das war halt so ein Kalender in politischer Hickhack. Also es war aber das einzige Beispiel, von dem ich weiß, wo wirklich,
es wirklich irgendwie so politisiert wurde. Und im Wesentlichen hat die Seuchenbekämpfungsbehörde hier so macht irgendwie so ihr Ding,
und hat dann halt am ersten zwölften gesagt, so ab ersten zwölften tragen wir jetzt alle wieder mehr Masken, weil jetzt grade sehr viele Fälle in der Quarantäne gefunden werden
so sechs pro Tag in Leuten, die im Hotel festsitzen. Ähm
Und dann wurden halt wieder Maskenpflichten eingeführt, mehr Leute haben angefangen Masken zu tragen. Ähm und die macht halt so ihr Ding, während sich die Leute aus der in der Politik über Schweinefleisch streiten.
Mhm.
Aber um zurückzukommen auf meine ursprüngliche Aussage, es wird alles zentral und sogar weitgehend auch nicht direkt von der Politik oder in die unmittelbar gesteuert durch die Politik äh entschieden. Es gibt
keine föderale Aufteilung und äh dementsprechend auch,
politische breite Diskussion, weil da bin ich mir auch noch nicht so hundertprozentig sicher, ob das nicht bei uns auch äh eine ganz erhebliche Spaßbremse gewesen ist. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich bin mir fast
schon sicher, dass das eine gewesen ist, aber ich kann's jetzt nicht irgendwie äh wissenschaftlich untermauern.
Na ja, so da es so als als vergleichende Politikwissenschaftlerin ähm würde ich dann nochmal auf die USA hinweisen, weil Föderalismus ist total toll, wenn man in kompetente Zentraleregierung hat.
Weil ich schon glaube, dass in den USA äh viele Gouverneurs durch ähm durchaus Leben gerettet haben, weil es halt einfach, weil sie teils sehr anders durchgegriffen haben. Und wenn das alles zentralisiert gewesen wäre, dann sehen die USA, glaube ich, jetzt noch deutlich schlimmer.
Das stimmt allerdings.
Zum Beispiel ich ich meine, ich promoviere halt an der Uni, die in Massachusetts basiert ist und in Master truics ähm sind die Maßnahmen, also das sieht auch grad alles nicht gut aus, aber die Maßnahmen waren teils strikter und irgendwie.
Wirken irgendwie vertrauenserweckender als zum Beispiel in in Deutschland. Ähm also wo auch die Regelung das teils die die Regelung des.
Statusmassages ist es teils sehr ernst genommen hat.
Ja, stimmt, das ist nicht der Föderalismus. Ja, das Problem ist das Problem, es ist einfach politische Inkompetenz, egal, ob sie föderal oder zentral organisiert ist.
So sieht's ja.
Der Gesichtsausdruck.
So sieht's aus. Beklopptheit ist immer das Problem.
Natürlich auch, dass man einfach Behörden hat, die solche Sachen machen können, ne, also auch einfach, dass es dass es hier, dass es einfach auch sehr, was ich sehr beeindruckend fand, ist so ein bisschen mitzukriegen, wie,
Die Behörden, die hier damit umgehen mussten, also die tabinesische Regierung ist Bürokratie ist nicht gerade unbedingt dafür bekannt, dass sie irgendwie total agil ist oder so
aber sie haben es wirklich geschafft auch mehrfach zum Beispiel mit diesem Beispiel mit der Kontakt nach Verfolgung auf Umstände zu reagieren und in Teils relativ schnell,
ihre Strategie auch zu ändern und anzupassen. Und Taiwan hat zum Beispiel auch zum Thema wie schnell muss man anfangen. Taiwan hat am einunddreißigsten oder dreißigsten Dezember zweitausendneunzehn angefangen, bei Leuten aus Wuhan Fieber zu messen.
Weil in Tai One spricht man halt auch Mandarinen. Die Leute können das chinesische Internet lesen und im chinesischen Internet gab es Gerüchte, dass es in Wuhan eine ähnliche eine neue SARS neuen SARS Ausbruch gibt,
hatten wir schon mal, war nicht gut,
Wir also tut nicht weh, wir messen jetzt zur Sicherheit mal Fieber bei allen Leuten, die aus Ruand kommen. Und haben damit halt sehr früh angefangen. Ähm und.
Haben dann im Endeffekt also so wie der Vertreter der solchen Bekämpfungshürde mir das erklärt hat, die haben halt im Endeffekt gesagt, okay, wir haben quasi ein Modell dafür, wie wir mit SARS umgehen. Wir tun jetzt, wir wir handeln das Ganze jetzt einfach so,
und wir passen uns dann an, wenn wir neue Informationen kriegen. Und das heißt, die haben so ein, so ein, so ein bisschen so einen internativen Prozess im Wesentlichen gehabt, die gesagt, wir machen wir machen das Beste, was wir machen können, basierend auf dem Wissen, das wir gerade haben und passen das dann regelmäßig an, wenn neue Erkenntnisse reinkommen. Und.
Ähm mein Eindruck ist, dass das deutlich schneller ging als zum Beispiel in Deutschland, wo dann halt Wochen diskutiert wird, bevor irgendwelche Sachen ähm verändert werden oder so.
Mit dem Ergebnis, dass wir,
halbgaren Maßnahmen zugucken, wie's immer schlimmer wird und jeder Tag, der ist schlimmer wird oder gleichbleibt, ist ein Tag, den wir verloren haben, ne? Das denke ich, das wird auch
jetzt nicht mehr allzu lange dauern, bis das jetzt auch mal die Kultur und Gastronomietreibenden auch mal wirklich scharf erkennen und sagen, naja, wisst ihr
wenn ihr die, wenn ihr uns wirklich mal, wenn ihr mal alles hier einfach vier Wochen zugemacht hättet, dann könnten wir jetzt unter dann hätten die Hygienekonzepte, die wir uns für unsere Clubs geschrieben haben vor Monaten,
irgendwann auch mal die Möglichkeit bekommen, an der Realität getestet zu werden. Und das ist ja das, was was ihnen die ganze Zeit auch versagt.
Und dazu muss man natürlich auch sagen, ein ganz großer Vorteil von diesen ganzen niedrigen Fallzahlen ist natürlich auch und das ist ja zum Beispiel in Korea so gewesen, man kriegt überhaupt erst mit, ob sich Leute in irgendwelchen Clubs
infizieren oder nicht, weil man diese ganz
dezidierte Kontaktnachverfolgung überhaupt machen kann. Das ist ja in Deutschland schon ganz lange so, dass wir irgendwie nie wirklich mehr detailliert darüber reden, wo sich Leute wirklich anstecken und die Datenlagen also lange immer sehr, sehr vage war.
Total dramatischer Punkt. Ich bin froh, dass du das ansprichst. Ich wir haben in den ersten Monat.
Ähm war das auch noch wirklich spannend, sage ich mal, die Forschungsergebnisse zu verfolgen, weil da viel Erkenntnisgewinn bei war, ja?
Mir scheint es, dass wir jetzt auf einmal in einer äh das wird kein kein nennenswerten Erkenntnisgewinn mehr bekommen über das äh über das Agieren,
Virus, genau das, weil wir, weil wir es auch gar nicht mehr wahrnehmen, das das bröckelt so über uns drüber. Wir haben in Deutschland irgendwie über fünfzig Prozent der Infektionen,
weiß man nicht, wo die herkommen, mit anderen Worten, gibt kein Modell, keine Chance, irgendeine Forschung dadurch zu näheren, das besser äh zu lernen und entsprechend,
können wir Maßnahmen betreiben? Ja, diese ganze Schulgeschichte, dass wir ein großes Thema hier in Deutschland, großes Thema sind Kinder ähm
ansteckend oder nicht? Du musst, wurde der Drosten für von der Bildzeitung irgendwie einmal gehäutet und ähm.
Durchs durchs Dorf gezogen und bis heute, also bis vor Kurzem waren die Schulen einfach noch offen, ja, während man sieht und sagt, okay, wir haben alles eigentlich zugemacht,
Die Zahlen gehen weiter hoch, aber so mal darüber nachzudenken, dass es eventuell an den Schulen gelegen haben könnte. Das kam einfach niemandem mehr in den Sinn, ne? Und diese.
Mir fehlt da einfach mal diese vergleichende Forschung. Da sage ich nur, hier wieder, Entschuldigung, noch mal Referenz zu Tim UKW. Diese ähm Studie, die ihr da äh kürzlich besprochen hattet, wo das ähm.
Wo geguckt wurde im Prinzip, wo man auf das Delta der Maßnahmen geschaut hat, ne, wo man gesagt hat, okay, wenn erst die Maßnahmen kommt, wie entwickeln sich die Zahlen, gibt es dann noch.
Weitere Varianzaufklärungen durch eine weitere Maßnahme oder wird schlimmer, wenn welche Maßnahme aufgehoben wird. Das sind dann so irgendwie die Studien, die man dazu noch findet, aber so.
Ich habe wirklich den Eindruck, dass so eine, ja, so eine Kapitulation.
Da ist und eigentlich aber alle wüssten so, das war schon immer irgendwie klar, machste.
Radikale Kontaktreduktion für einen Zeitraum von vier Wochen, kann es nur runtergehen, weil das Virus von den Kontakten lebt, also musst du die halt äh aus dem Weg kegeln, aber diesen, das wird halt irgendwie.
Ja, ich es ist irgendwie zum zum ähm zum Haare raufen, dass das halt nicht mehr,
überhaupt in Betracht kommt, weil man eben mit diesen Halbgarn-Maßnahmen die Leute jetzt schon längst soweit hat, dass sie aufm Zahnfleisch gehen.
Genau, ich glaube, das ist das Problem mit dieser Müdigkeit, ne, die du und das sehen wir halt in Asien, die kriegst du halt auf jeden Fall einfach auch, also egal, wie es ist und das Problem ist halt, dass es in Deutschland so
größtenteils ineffiziente Maßnahmen waren. Und weil man eben auch so ein bisschen auf Sicht fährt, weil man eben diese Information nicht hat und ich glaube für mich, also was ich auch jetzt merke,
dadurch, dass ich hier viel detaillierter mitkriege. So, man kann halt jeden Tag ja auf den Twitter-Account des Gesundheitsministeriums hier gehen und das sagen sie einem, das sind die drei Fälle, die wir heute gefunden haben
Das ist direkt das Ergebnis unserer Kontaktnachverfolgung. Hier hat sich diese Person infiziert so. Ähm und das heißt, man hat halt auch als so Bürgerinnen viel,
Also man hat Zugriff auf viel mehr Informationen, die einem auch irgendwie Informationen geben, die nützlich sind.
Wenn ich weiß, dass jemand krank ist und andere Leute in dem Flugzeug infiziert, weil er keine Maske aufhatte, das sagt, gibt mir wichtige Informationen. So, dass es wichtig ist, Maske zu tragen,
Innenräume drin, das war eine Infektion im Flugzeug. Es gibt Infektionen im Flugzeug. Ähm so solche Sachen.
Oder es gab eine spannende Studie vor ein paar Wochen aus ähm Korea, Südkorea
dass jemand jemand anderen im Restaurant angesteckt hat. Die waren sehr weit voneinander entfernt weiter, weil deutlich weiter als eins Komma fünf Meter. Ähm aber und die eine Person war nur für fünf Minuten drin und trotzdem hat sie sich angesteckt.
Oder was total, was auch ein bisschen ähm ist, äh was es aus China gerade gibt, in China gibt es jetzt mehrfach Fälle, die auf importiertes Fleisch zurückgeführt wurden.
Wo genau das.
Von Tönnies.
Tatsächlich war das eine deutsches Schweinefleisch. Ähm aber wo ähm.
Aber wo äh also das Problem ist in China ist natürlich auch alles immer ein bisschen politisiert. Aber es fällt schon auf, dass es jetzt mehrfach so Hafen oder Flugzeugmitarbeiter in größtenteils im Norden gab
die scheinbar sich infiziert haben von Virus, der wohl auf irgendwelchem gefrorenen Fleisch außen dran war. Ähm und solche Sachen, also so detaillierte Kontaktnachverfolgung, ich weiß nicht, ob die in Deutschland jemals möglich war
ähm
Aber dass also das das findet halt grade nur in so Staaten statt, wo die Zahlen halt sind durch sind. Und das bedeutet aber auch, dass man viel mehr weiß darüber, was was die Gefahrenquellen sind. Und was dann eben auch Maßnahmen informieren kann, aber was auch Bürger,
in Deutschland ja jetzt über Eigenverantwortung reden, das können Bürgerinnen auch nutzen, um für sich diese besser zu entscheiden, was sind wirklich gefährliche Situationen? Weil grade wird immer also nur gesagt, es hat alles gefährlich, wahrscheinlich auch grade,
nicht falsch in Deutschland, aber ähm irgendwie vor ein paar Monaten wär's für mich schon voll gut gewesen zu wissen, so was für Situationen sind denn konkret in Situationen, in denen sich Leute anstecken, das das hätte ich tatsächlich schon gerne gewusst, um mein Verhalten so ein bisschen besser anpassen zu können.
Ist auch nicht nur die Kontaktverfolgung. Man sieht ja jetzt auch gerade durch den Fall in äh Großbritannien, dass natürlich auch diese.
Eine wichtige Rolle spielt. Ich würde mal vermuten, ich weiß es jetzt nicht.
Bei den wenigen Fällen hinter waren, dass das sozusagen ohnehin nebenbei noch mitgemacht wird, also wenn man da jetzt wirklich positiv getestet, wird das dann auch gleich eine Sequenzierung vorgenommen wird, also dass man sich quasi die äh äh das Erbgut des Virus äh anschaut und dann eben auch,
bestimmen kann, wo kommt das her, ne? Ähm das läuft
Das ist übrigens eine der Sachen, die in UK ganz gut laufen und das äh mag auch der Grund gewesen sein, dass sie jetzt diesen neuen Virusubtyp auch überhaupt auf die Spur gekommen sind, während das halt in Deutschland
da auch ganz schlimm aussieht. Also wir sind da ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz weit hinten. Ja.
Und ich äh wo man sich halt einfach auch, ich glaube, die große Frage ist halt so ein bisschen ähm für mich weil ganz viele Leute net irgendwie sagen so, oh Asien steht nur so gut da, weil sie schon.
Asiaten sind, weil's da überall in Asien so warm ist und natürlich auch Quatsch ist, B ist so.
Peking hat irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wie viel Minus Grade im Winter ähm oder weil sie alle Inseln sind, ist auch Quatsch. Ähm aber was tatsächlich, glaube ich, schon eine Rolle spielt, ist die Erfahrung mit früheren Pandemieausbrüchen,
und deswegen ist, glaube ich, eine auch ich habe noch ähm ein guter Freund von mir, ist in Australien, der ist in Sydney glaube ich gerade und der meinte in ähm Australien hat ähm haben frühere Probleme,
dieses ganze System sehr informiert und waren halt eine wichtige Grundlage dafür. Und ich glaube eine ganz wichtige Frage, wenn man jetzt vorwärts geht in die Zukunft ist nicht nur also jetzt natürlich kurzfristig, wie können wir Menschen retten,
und also Menschenleben retten, ähm aber langfristiger ist auch die Frage, wie können wir diese Erfahrung,
nicht nur unter den Teppich kehren, sondern anerkennen, dass ähm es ein Problem gab und daraus lernen.
Weil in Taiwan wurde das geschafft in in China H, also haben wir also so,
die Systeme, die eigentlich einen neuen ASAS-Ausbruch verhindern sollten, ähm haben nicht wirklich angeschlagen aus politischen Gründen im Januar,
Ähm und das heißt, die große Frage ist eigentlich, schaffen wir es, daraus zu lernen? Um ähm falls sowas noch mal passiert, besser dazustehen oder ähm sagen wir, wenn alle geimpft sind, so.
Oh Gott, lasst einfach nie wieder drüber reden. Das ist für mich so ein bisschen die große Frage.
In der nächsten Pandemie wird alles besser.
Aber also ernsthaft, ne? Also das ist halt wirklich, also natürlich kann man dann so tun, okay, das war jetzt einmal, wird nie wieder passieren oder man kann sich halt ähm wie in hinsetzen und sagen, wir haben's verbockt, wir müssen beim ersten Mal besser vorbereitet sein.
Gut äh Katharina, ich denke, jetzt haben wir das hier auch ausreichend erörtert. Linus, hast du noch irgendwas, was du nachtragen möchtest.
Nee, in mir, in mir staut sich jetzt halt auch so eine Welle aus Neid und Missgunst, langsam auf, ähm sodass wir die Sendung vielleicht langsam beenden.
Linus will wieder Reven gehen.
Eine Sache, die ich tatsächlich am Ende gern noch sagen würde, ist, dass ich glaube, äh.
Ich finde, ich ich beobachte die ganze Sache, Deutschland halt schon seit März so ein bisschen fassungslos, weil ich hatte von Anfang an die Reaktionen, diversen asiatischen Ländern mitgekriegt habe,
Und ich glaube, ich habe lange das Gefühl gehabt, dass in Deutschland so ein bisschen.
Das ist schwer vorstellbar ist, wie es das anders sein könnte und ich habe so ein bisschen wo ich so ein bisschen.
Angst habe, dass wir uns das einfach nicht vorstellen können und dass wir deswegen an uns als Gesellschaft so niedrigen Anspruch haben und auch an die Regierung einen niedrigen Anspruch haben. Weil eigentlich sollte ja unsere das, was wir von der Regierung verlagen und von uns als Gesellschaft verlangen sein, dass wir mit so einer Sache vernünftig umgehen. Und,
da gut dran arbeiten. Und wenn man, wie ich das jetzt die letzten Monate hatte.
So ein Muster hat die ganze Zeit die ganze Zeit sieht, was in Ostasien teils gemacht wird
und wie es gut laufen kann und dann also die die Schere zu Deutschland ist einfach so offensichtlich. Die ist vielleicht nicht offensichtlich, wenn man sich nur einmal kurz damit auseinandersetzt, irgendwie hört, das ist alles nur, weil sie Überwachung haben. Das ist alles nur, was sie Asiaten sind,
aber wenn man das wirklich in real so in echt Zeit mitverfolgt und mit Leuten redet, die das durchmachen, ich kenne so viele Leute, die zwischen die in dieser Zeit
nach Asien zurückgereist sind und strikte Quarantäne gemacht haben, darüber geschrieben haben, wie es ist, einzureisen. Ähm
wie es ist, dort zu leben gerade, was die Behörden machen, so diese ganzen Sachen. Ähm da gibt's total verschiedene Erfahrungen in Demokratien, in autoritären Ländern, aber was viele von ihnen gemeinsam haben, ist, dass man die ganze Zeit das Gefühl hat, die Behörden nehmen das viel ernster. Und in meinen eigenen Erfahrungen,
In Deutschland habe ich immer das Gefühl gehabt, so macht ihr eigentlich irgendwas. Also das war eine total, das war eine das war eine ganz krasse Erfahrung und wo ich, glaube ich, schon das Gefühl habe, dass es sehr deutlich informiert wird, dass ich überhaupt diese
diese parallele Perspektive, dieser parallele Film, der die ganze Zeit nebenher läuft für mich. Und ich glaube, es ist wichtig, dass wir uns, also dass wir lernen, uns das vorstellen zu können und auch lernen über den Tellerrand zu schauen und ähm
auch bereit sind von uns und von den von der Regierung, von unserer Regierung in Europa das reinzufordern.
Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, das ist,
also Deutschland ruht sich da ähnlich äh wie seine Automobilindustrie auch so ein paar äh äh Erfolgen der Vergangenheit aus, ne? Also es ist schon so, dass man,
dass dass die Leute hier dann schon durchaus stolz sagen, ja also entschuldige mal bitte, ne? Wir haben ja wohl hier,
den PCR-Test erfunden und,
Impfstoffe, die sind hier auch von unseren Forscher, Teams und Forscherinnen ähm und selbst hier deutsche Unternehmen, die hier gegründet wurden, ne? Wir sind ja hier ganz weit vorne und es gab ja dann auch in.
Das müsst ihr dann außer April, Mai gewesen sein. Wirklich auch positive Berichterstattung weltweit, wie Deutschland irgendwie die Situation geklärt hat, ne? Und es gab positive Berichterstattungen über die App. Und in all diesen Bereichen siehst du aber
das total zerfällt, ne? Also diese an dieser App, nachdem die einmal gelobt wurde, wurde dann nicht mehr nennenswert dran weiterentwickelt. Die PCR-Testerei hat irgendwann auf einmal in Deutschland abgenommen, wurde das
Regime geändert. Impfstoffe, OK wollen wir mal schauen, Sie sparen das jetzt noch vor die Wand, fährt aber ich bin mir sicher, er hat einen konkreten Plan und,
während all dessen sitzt man dann hier, lässt irgendwie so die Maßnahmen über sich ergehen und alles, was sich dann noch regt an.
Kritik und Zweifel kommt dann auch tatsächlich eben aus dieser,
covidiotischen Ecke, ne? Ich meine, ich habe hier auch die Erfahrung gemacht, dass ich irgendwann sehr früh im Logbuch ähm mich für.
Also als,
müsste jetzt müsst ihr nochmal raussuchen, aber gibt's bestimmt, kann man in den Kommentaren sehen, als im Prinzip die ersten, also die ersten Maßnahmen, ich glaube noch durch
von Angela Merkel formuliert wurden und ich gesagt habe,
Ich hätte mir gewünscht, dass hier sofort mit dem Hammer draufgehauen wird und es konkrete Ausgangssperren und so weiter gibt und die Sache dann in paar Wochen im Griff ist. Was ich da dann natürlich auch ähm,
ja an an Feedback bekommen habe, ne, von ähm von Leuten, die das irgendwie als Protofaschistische hin und her äh bezeichnet haben und diese Leute leiden inzwischen seit ähm.
Vielen Monaten, an letztendlich nie wirklich gelüfteten Einschränkungen und äh ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass ähm,
dass es damit alles hätte verhindert werden können, aber ich bilde mir zumindest ein, dass wir vielleicht einen cooleren Sommer gehabt hätten, wenn wir,
einmal gemacht hätten. Aber das ist so das, worüber die Diskussion jetzt hier noch geht und sowas wie du jetzt schilderst mit der ähm Quarantäne äh Kontroll,
mit den Quarantänekontrollmöglichkeiten. Das finde ich sehr spannend als als äh Ergebnis aus diesem Gespräch, weil das klingt wirklich, weißt du ja sicherlich auch für Deutsche äh oder für diesen Kulturkreis hier, für
wie eine absolute Katastrophe, ne. Das ist das ist so die der absolute Irrsinns zu machen. Da sind die Leute, glaube ich, die sind eher bereit zu sagen, trackt mich die ganze Zeit,
zu sagen, überwacht mal in der Quarantäne, dass ich zu Hause bleibe. Das, da sagen die Leute, Wahnsinn. Ne? Das ist wirklich sehr ähm.
Sehr faszinierend.
Ich glaube eine Sache, die also für mich find's auch wichtig, also für mich ist auch meine eine, also meine große Conclusio so aus dieser ganzen,
und danach aus allem, was ich jetzt aus den letzten Monaten aus den asiatischen Reaktionen auch gelernt habe, ist das, glaube ich, jede Antwort auf die Pandemie, die nur auf eine Sache sich verlässt, ist zum Scheitern verurteilt.
Also kein, also die taunesische Regierung hat ähm,
oder es war die Beregnung mit solchen Bekämpfungsbehörde, die haben Mitte Januar oder Ende Januar, als der erste Fall dann da war, ein Maßnahmenkatalog mit über hundert verschiedenen Maßnahmen rausgegeben, wo sie gesagt haben, wir machen das jetzt alles um die Pandemie unter Kontrolle zu kriegen. Und haben es dann eben auch ohne Lockdown geschafft.
Und ähm ich glaube, alles, was ich nur auf eine Sache fokussiert, also sei es irgendwie elektronische Überwachung der Quarantäne, sei es nur Quarantäne, sei es irgendwie Contact Tracing, sei es Testen, ähm also alles, was nur sich auf eine Sache fokussiert
Das kann einfach nicht. Also es reicht einfach nicht und das ist ähm was man hier auch sieht, deswegen,
Also als einer der Gründe, warum das immer ich bisher noch keinen kurzen, knackigen Text über die terminesische Antwort auf die Pandemie geschrieben habe, weil es so kompliziert ist. Und es sind einfach so viele Sachen, die zusammenspielen und die alle voneinander abhängen. Ähm und deswegen muss man da einfach
es ist eine viel komplexere Antwort. Und dann immer nur zu sagen, die App wird uns retten, das testen wir uns retten. Das ist alles ist gefühlt, es ist alles viel zu kurz gedacht. Und,
es scheint so ein bisschen in Asien sieht man so ein bisschen, dass was zu funktionieren scheint, sind viele verschiedene Sachen, die einander unterstützen und die dann im Zusammenspiel helfen.
Und vielleicht ein bisschen Glück, aber das wäre das wäre sehr viel Glück gewesen in Asien.
Jetzt wird uns der Impfstoff retten.
Das erinnert mich an Kims, äh Red Flags, wo sie sagt, ähm ne, also es ist ein Allheilmittel.
Es ist allen bekannt und es wird trotzdem und trotzdem wird's dir verheimlicht, so wenn wenn diese oder wird's allen verwehrt,
wenn diese Redflex hat natürlich auch irgend so ein Gelaber von da, du musst nur den Datenschutz abschaffen und schon hast du die äh Pandemie im Griff, ne.
Oder du musst nur eine App haben oder du musst nur diese eine Maßnahme machen und dann ist alles äh gelöst. Wobei ich das einschränken würde für tatsächlich ähm so.
Das Einzige, wo man ganz klar sagen kann, das hilft und das ist irgendwie wissenschaftlich unumstritten wäre halt tatsächlich die Leute.
Paar Wochen zu Hause halten, ne? Das ist das ist tatsächlich das einzige, was die Wissenschaft hergibt, aber dann noch lange nicht, dass du damit langfristig irgendwas im Griff hättest. Und das ist ja, glaube ich, der Teil ähm.
Den Taiwan eben hinbekommen hat, mit wie du eben sagst, auch sehr vielen Maßnahmen.
Und es ist das wert, ne? Also deswegen auch nochmal diese ganze Sache mit dem ohrgott, man wird zwei Wochen überwacht. Also zwei Wochen sieht die Regierung, dass sich in einem Hotelzimmer sitze, dass ich eh nicht verlassen darf.
Okay, also ich mag also wir sagen ja Deutschland immer so dieses ich habe nichts zu verbergen, ist problematisch, aber in dem Fall habe ich bei meiner Location tatsächlich nichts zu verbergen. Ähm.
Es ist der, es ist der uninteressanteste Location-Datensatz, den du deinem Leben generieren wirst, ne, also vierzehn Tage Einstand.
Und und danach.
Ist wirklich sehr.
Und danach habe ich dann mehr Freiheiten als ich seit März oder irgendeinem anderen in irgendeinem europäischen oder nordamerikanischen Land gehabt haben könnte. Und also ich glaube, das ist auch vielen.
Viele Leute, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, die es auch gemacht haben, sagen, das ist ihnen halt wert. Die machen das, weil das hat ein Ende und danach weiß man, woran man ist.
Und ähm das ist ihn wert, weil man den Preis nur für zwei Wochen zahlt im statt für mehrere Monate.
Viel zu einfach. Das wäre halt viel zu einfach. Das muss viel komplizierter sein.
Ich würde sagen, wir müssen erstmal sechzehn äh Landeschefinnen drüber diskutieren, ohne jeglichen Rat von Expertinnen oder so. Das dann dann können wir das einfacher hinkriegen. Äh komplizierter hinkriegen.
Ach ähm nee, das nee, das habe ich eine Sache, die ich auch noch sagen wollte, ist, ich finde es spannend, dass in Taiwan niemand über den Impfstoff redet bisher. Das ist kein Thema,
weil äh das ist halt eher so ein, ich glaube auch nicht, dass ähm äh also das ist so ein bisschen die große Frage ist, wie Tai-Run sich aus der also ob ob
ob es hier einen Plan gibt, um aus der Pandemie rauszukommen, weil das halt auch keine Lösung ist, die Ganzen eh wichtig zu halten, aber so was die Risikobereitschaft hier angeht, würde ich nicht sagen, dass die terministische Regierung, ähm das ausreichend findet, zu sagen,
dass nur ein paar Leute nicht krank werden und dass vielleicht dann doch wieder irgendwie diverse Infektionen im Land stattfinden. Also das heißt, es wird die das ist so ein bisschen.
Auch da sind die Maßstäbe gerade ganz, sind Maßstäbe, glaube ich, andere als in Europa. Oder in Nordamerika gerade.
Das finde ich gut. Die sollen sich mal später mit dem Impfstoff beschäftigen. Dann bleibt erstmal genug für uns übrig.
Nee, die also die bestellen auch so, ne, aber also ich habe auch und ich habe auch neulich von einer ähm ein, einer, einer Ärztin, die unter anderem für die Nigerianische Regierung, glaube ich, arbeitet, mit deren Interview und MPR ähm
die auch meinte, so auch zum Beispiel afrikanische Länder, die ähm die Pandemie deutlich besser bewältigt haben bisher als Europa, müssen sich auch überlegen, ob es überhaupt sinnvoll ist, Leute zu impfen, ähm weil das eine sehr große Ausgabe ist und die und ähm in den Ländern teils Covid neunzehn im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Problemen
gar nicht so schlimm ist.
Das heißt auch diese ganze Impfokussierung ist wirklich so ein ist ein sehr ähm westliches, so ein sehr, sehr westliches Ding. Wobei China auch sehe auf dieser ganzen Impfstoffsache.
Ähm wir sind da auch sehr hinterher, aber so in Taiwan habe ich das Gefühl, das ist besser noch gar kein Thema ist.
Weil das halt auch nicht so als das Allheilmittel grad gesehen wird. Das geht jetzt gerade erst mal so darum, den Ausbruch jetzt hier zu verhindern. Ähm lange ging's darum, überhaupt einen Ausbruch zu verhindern.
Und Impfstoff ist so ein bisschen in der relativ weiten Ferne, obwohl die Regelung sich auch schon einige Dosen gesichert hat, aber.
Das kannst du abmoderieren, Tim.
Nur wenn du alles gesagt hast, was du loswerden möchtest, Katharina.
Also wir hören dich ja gerne reden, also von daher habe ich da gar kein Problem mit.
Das kann man übrigens auch bei Fernostwärts äh Deutschlands bester Asien Podcast. Ist die Selbst.
Wir haben das wir haben das irgendwann einfach mal dran geschrieben, weil wir dachten, es gibt nicht so viele andere, oder? Oder gibt's andere? Okay, wir schreiben's mal dran, weil wir der Einzige sind.
Aber uns gibt es, uns gibt es seit zweitausendfünfzehn, also wir machen das schon äh eine ganze Weile oder zweitausendvierzehn sogar, also ja.
Revidieren, aber genau, es gibt einen Podcast.
Genau und wir haben auch eine Episode mit dir schon mal vorgeführt zwei Jahren oder so aufgezeichnet über ähm China größten im weitesten Sinne.
Die verlinken wir auch nochmal in den hast du sonst noch etwas was in verlinken soll? Ich vermute du hattest auf Twitter noch von der neuesten Folge geschwärmt.
Sollen wir die auch nochmal direkt verlinken?
Genau, da kann man machen, also einfach, weil es sehr, ähm, ich habe mit äh C Young gesprochen, das ist ein äh junger chinesischer Journalist. Es gibt
unheimlich viele talentierte junge chinesische Journalistinnen und ich hab er ist einer von denen mit den ich unbedingt mal sprechen wollte es war eine sehr spannende Unterhaltung und wir haben über Queerides in China geredet und wie es ist.
Nicht in der Kür zu sein, er hat darüber geredet wie Schule, Chinesen Kinder kriegen können.
Und warum äh gleichgeschlechtliche Liebesgeschichten politisch sensibel sind und zensiert werden. Das war eine sehr spannende Unterhaltung.
Und eine Sache, die ich tatsächlich auch noch pluggen würde, ist, dass wir für bei Fernost wird's mittlerweile auch einen Newsletter haben, ähm wo wir so.
Alle zwei Wochen ähm Nachrichten aus aus Asien zusammenfassen. Also das ähm aus China, Hongkong und Taiwan.
Das ist so ein bisschen so ein Versuch.
Eine regelmäßige Quelle für Nachrichten aus Ostasien zu schaffen. Das heißt, wenn ihr euch, wenn ihr nicht nur über die Region lesen wollt, wenn gerade irgendwas explodiert, ähm oder,
Irgendwie Stress gibt, sondern immer so ein bisschen so einfach so generell so ein bisschen unterschwellig verfolgen wollt, was dann gerade immer so los ist, ähm dann äh genau gibt's dafür,
Newsletter. Und da könnt ihr zum Beispiel auch nachlesen, warum in Taiwan gerade alle über Schweinefleisch streiten.
Super, das nehmen wir alles mit auf in die Shownotes. Tim, möchtest du noch äh was loswerden?
Na ja, ich denke, wir haben jetzt hier alles äh aufgearbeitet, was jetzt erstmal zu dem Thema zu sagen ist. Dann bleibt uns eigentlich erstmal nur uns zu bedanken, Katharina. Vielen Dank.
Danke für die Einladung.
Ja, wirklich vielen Dank. Wir hatten hier einige ja, einige Probleme mit der Aufzeichnung technischer Natur, weil wir ja hier
ähm man man darf einfach nicht vergessen, so die Internetabdeckung in so Entwicklungsländern ist halt relativ schlecht und das war für Katharina natürlich jetzt auch eine neue Erfahrung hier mit zwei Deutschen,
versuchen zu müssen, 'ne Internetverbindung herzustellen, ja? Und da eben einfach
Ja, dass da die Bandbreiten und die äh Zuverlässigkeit der Verbindung dann einfach
dann nicht den den heimesischen äh Erwartungen entspricht. Das ist natürlich dann auch ähm das erfordert Geduld,
danken wir dir, außerdem, dass du dir zur Nacht die Zeit genommen hast, mit uns noch äh darüber zu sprechen.
Ähm und dann habe ich ja schon gesagt, dass ich am Ende dieses Jahres aufhören werde, persönlich zu danken, weil es zu oft zu.
Missverständnissen und Auslassung in dem Bereich kam und deswegen, weil das Jahr noch nicht zu Ende ist.
Weiter.
Ich. Pascal, Sven, Katrin, Olaf, Stefan, Paul, Florian, Oliver und Till,
sehr herzlich für Unterstützung.
Und ich damit bedanke mich fürs Zuhören und fürs äh Wiedereinschalten und überhaupt und äh für eure Hörer äh und Hörerinnentreue und äh wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss.
Ciao ciao.